Gut morgen Tim.
Wenn sie auf mich aufzunehmen sie halten das Mikrofon direkt auf mich zu sie begehen eine Straftat.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 265 265, 16562 vom 23 August 2018 direct live,
roh ungefiltert aus der Metaebene.
Ja und wir haben wieder schlechte Nachrichten.
Das Schild das schlechteste was zu finden war aber zusammen g******,
wirklich den ganzen Staub auf.
Nur die feinsten der schlechten Nachrichten.
Wie viel bewegen I fein säuberlich zusammen oder kaufen mit dem Laubbläser und ich pushe euch das einfach ist.
Nur dass es dann noch fest klebt das nehmen wir nur was da noch Festnetz ist scheiße genug um euch damit die Laune zu versauen.
Therapiert deine Laune ist auch ein bisschen versaut.
Meine Laune ist nachhaltig versaut ich war ja letzte Woche bei bei in den Fan räumen des FC St Pauli wunderschönes willkommen,
VOL.at wirklich toll toll aufbereitet viele Leute da wunderschön ich habe noch ein T-Shirt bekommen sehr schönes T-Shirt habe ich bekommen,
steht drauf ganz Hamburg spielt in Liga zwei.
Ja das ist sehr schön.
Nee war wirklich nett,
tut mir leid dass ich da du wahrscheinlich den schlechtesten und deprimierenden Vortrag meines Lebens gehalten habe die Aufgabe war ja mal so ein bisschen ausgehend halt von der Fußball Fanszene.
Über halt polizeiliche mit uns Methoden Befugnisse und,
Missbrauch dieser Befugnisse vorzutragen mich in die bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung angefangen gegenüber Videoüberwachung und Staatstrojaner und hast du alles nicht gesehen also über die letzten 18 12 Jahre gegangen.
Das war nachhaltig
beeindrucken ich habe gedacht das kannst du aus dem ff das hast ja alles begleitet ob bei netzpolitik.org oder hier im Podcast oder als Vertreter des CCC
na ich war erstmal längere viel länger damit beschäftigt die Scheiße zusammentragen zu tragen als ich dachte und.
Ja habe dann jetzt endlich die Antwort gefunden weil wir so oft gefragt sein aber wie schafft ihr das immer so gute Laune zu behalten die Antwort lautet wir müssen ja immer nur eine Woche behandeln also pro Sendung kriegen wir ja nur eine Woche.
Digitales.
Disaster und das kann man dann noch so grob mit viel Mühe und viel Sarkasmus aufarbeiten,
aber wenn man da mal so offen etwas mehr als der Dekade blickt dann bleibt einem das Lachen schon im Halse stecken.
Du kannst den Interview mit Steven Kohl bergeseen war auch gefragt wurde werde das erträgt wie jeden Tag seiner Late Show,
mal wieder so viele Jobs zu reisen rund um Trump und sonst noch alles ganz furchtbar mandaya wäre auch alles ganz furchtbar aber,
aber trotzdem nicht mit aufhören weil er Spaß so würde er sich auch selber helfen das sozusagen.
Ja da war der nicht auch einer von denen die kurzfristig so fertig waren dass sie überlegt hatten die Sendung einzustellen.
Oder so in so eine Sinnkrise gestürzt wurden weil jetzt irgendwie das was sie vorher Wiese Politik vorher dargestellt haben in der Sendung ist dann tatsächlich auch so war also meine damalige so ein Bericht gelesen zu haben.
Habe ich jetzt aus dem Interview nicht so ganz raus gehört das war so ein bisschen der Fuchs.
Dierse dieses election night special was er gemacht hat und sie hat Einhaltung wie drei verschiedene Szenarien vorbereitet mit Witzen und ein Spieler je nachdem wieso das alles ausgeht aber auf das eine Szenario rentensicherheit also das was dann eintraf haben sich halt überhaupt nicht,
drauf vorbereiten.
Welches Final dass Trump die Wahl eigentlich verliert aber auch.
Gewinnt sie Wahl und Jana sag mal so Trump gewinnt die Wahl und es ist an dem Abend auch klar dass er das tut.
Unten das,
Szenario man sie hätten sie nicht vorbereitet weil das wollte sich halt auch niemand vorstellen und niemand wäre in der Lage gewesen dafür Witze zu machen,
so dass sie dann halt in dieser Situation waren diese komplette Sendung mehr oder weniger aus dem Stegreif zu machen und ich hatte die damals nicht gesehen ich habe sie jetzt einteilen mal kurz nachgeschaut und da sieht man mal auch mal wieder was,
7qb für ein Gewinn für dieses Land ist,
weil er halt irgendwie auch aus Scheiße noch eine Situation erzeugen kann wo die Leute zu Missy Hoffnung nicht verlieren wenn das so
bis wir auch schaffen und Franziska gleichmäßig Rückkehr gleichzusetzen so dann wär ja auch schon was du.
Bin mal gespannt was die Fankurve jetzt daraus macht das entweder meine Ford in nur 8 von 18 Anklagepunkten schuldig gesprochen wurde,
und dieses wunderschöne sind jetzt ist es ja gerade so das Gefühl 94 Mal,
des der des der des Ende der Präsidentschaft Donald Trumps,
herbei fantasiert wird ich bin da inzwischen ohne jegliche Illusionen lege mich auch jetzt fest darüber wird er nicht stolpern allein schon deshalb weil das einzige was sie ihm.
Was Sie E-Mails bisher anhängen könnten ist dieser Vorwurf der illegalen Wahlkampfunterstützung,
durch das Dorf auf dem Computer gut dass ich ein laptopschutz habe,
dadurch eigentlich nehme ein LMP 200 Taschentuch die liegen hier bei uns immer bereit und trockne den Tisch.
Ich habe ja noch ein Original Metaebene Küchenrolle hilft auch immer extrem.
Mit original Michael Küchenrolle bestellen Sie jetzt wo waren wir Donald Trump Irak Einwohner.
Ja meine Ford also ich meine.
Ja meine Frau TV channel fort und dann gibt's ja noch diese Geschichte mit dem Kauen und das Diakon hat das ja wie im Bilderbuch gemacht das album is auch etwas was mir vorher gar nicht so klar war wie man denn wie man Leute besticht,
eine Geschichte nicht zu veröffentlichen und das funktioniert ja hier sehr schön von Korn illustriert durch den Kauf der rechte
Nährwerte eine eine Unternehmen gegründet so eine Shell company und hat dann mit dieser Shell company die Exklusivrechte an den Geschichten von Karen mcdougal und,
Stephanie Clifford gekauft und ehrlich gesagt halte ich das für absolut rechtens ist doch seine ist doch ein freies Land
und am Ende ist es ja keine Camp campaign Konto contribution weil
ja das Geld ja nachher in Raten a 35 000 Euro pro Monat von Donald Trump unter fingierten Rechnung für Beratungsdienstleistungen wieder zurück bekommen hat und das ist doch eine glasklare Sache dass das hier war ein absolut ekelhafte Nummer ist,
und aber nicht in irgendeiner Form juristisch bedenklich.
Na ich denke dass der aktuelle Fall meiner Ford der ist ja im Prinzip auch an related du bist jetzt schon mal den zweiten Teil Cronin man den meisten umrührer werden vermutlich diesen
ganzen Trump Vorgang nicht in der Intensität verfolgen wie es für uns beide eine Obsession geworden ist,
naja ich dicke Sofa Brisa genauso viel zu viel Zeit mit wie ich gerade.
Ja mein Arzt rät mir auch davon ab.
Das Positive ist.
Dieser investigation von diesem Robert Maler hat halt mit diesem Fall überhaupt erstmal bewiesen dass das alles Substanz hat und dass der Vorwurf dass es diese nicht hätte nicht zu erhalten ist ob das jetzt selber verändert,
da bin ich ganz bei dir nein das sind alles erste Schritte und wir wissen ja noch gar nicht was hier alles noch ausgegraben wird ich vermute ja das Größe.
Das tiefste Loch was hier gegraben wird das hat wie alles was mit dem ganzen Finanz Abhängigkeiten von Trump zu tun und sind immer rausfinden warum die Russen Ihnen alles so am Arsch haben dann.
Das also ich wenn Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt aber.
Dimata am Anfang von Anfang an mit diesem mit seinen Steuer Füchsen davon ja es ist ja somit die härtesten Vögel die das amerikanische Justizsystem so hervorgebracht hat,
und wenn sie eben da auf die Schliche kommen wird Sport gut.
Nico semsrott die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt ja aber sie stirbt dass ich das bei Donald Trump auch ganz ehrlich.
Ja mal kurz mal schauen wie rostet.
Habe ich übrigens auch sehr schön hier werden Mit unglückskekse gegessen letztens.
Unglückskekse sowas gibt es auch.
Sind die auch ein Produkt aus dem Hause ich weiß werde mir von welchem Verlag das sind Glückskekse mit mit mit Heizöl Nico semsrott Botschaften drin.
Ah jetzt direkt von ihm oder ihr seid alle also alani.
Ich glaube da steht drauf die Waren von Nico semsrott und.
Das stand über drauf möge dein Leben einmal so schön sein wie du es auf Facebook darstellst fand ich auch sehr schön genug Werbung für.
Nico semsrott genau der mir was schönes gewünscht netter netter junger Mann.
Ja dass ich mein Leben so schönes wie auf Facebook wo ich nicht vertreten bin.
QuoVadis über dich weiß.
Doch ich bin ich bin doch auf Facebook ich also ich kann gegen meinen Willen.
Habe ich nämlich schon mal Tattoo du wahrscheinlich auch du bist auch auf Facebook denn du bist ein Interesse.
Voll voll interessant.
Komm wir achso hier frohen Botschaften am Anfang haben wir uns ja vorgenommen gibt's immer eine frohe Botschaft,
eine die frohe Botschaft ist sehr froh,
Mode ja vor einigen Sendung bei uns zu Gast war wo vom openlab und von den Zwiebel Freundin,
na das Ziel dieser Untersuchung war und dann ziehe wegen Ermittlungen oder verdächtig dawca der Vorbereitung eines explosions oder Strahlung Verbrechens,
Tiervermittlung wurden nun eingestellt,
unglaublich hatte relativ schnell von der Staatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt bekommen der Vorwurf ist vom Tisch das war eine absolute Hexenjagd möchte ich sagen Rutsche.
Shunt Waltons.
So dass man die guten Nachrichten kommen wir nun zum Feedback das sind teilweise gute Nacht.
Werden es gibt zwei Feedbacks die wir in die Sendung aufgenommen haben es gab relativ viel Feedback zur letzten Sendung die meisten haben beim Formulieren des Feedbacks auch ihre Contenance gewahrt das freut mich immer wieder.
Bewertung Feedback Carmen von ms-pro,
ja sich auf deinen Nebensatz bezog wo du meintest Hillary Clinton habe ja.
Julian Assange.
Julian Assange Drohnen wollen das ist so ein Leben im Internet und das ist,
wir selber schreibt hier weil ich das häufiger höre die Behauptung dass Hillary Clinton Julien Assange Drogen wollte ist unbelegt und mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit eine reine Erfindung sie wurde von der wenig glaubwürdigen wird seit fupanet in die Welt gesetzt und mit Hinweis auf Kreisen des Außenministeriums,
zitiert das richtig und auf snipes.com wird es etwas ausführlicher noch dargestellt und das einzige was ich da überhaupt
finden diese sind irgendwelche E-Mails wo diskutiert wird wie man denn nun mit dem Fall Julien aus Haarschaum geht und dann ist in anderen Formulierung von Liegelind Nonnen liege
measures die Rede also legale und nicht legale wobei nicht legal.
Mittelital and non Lieferservice.
Erstens damit nicht zu verwechseln und vor allem nicht zu verwechseln mit Mund also mit illige weil non Liga heißt nur nicht sich aufrecht beziehend nicht
billiger als,
also mit anderen Worten Diplomatie oder pa oder was auch immer also irgendwas was nicht mit rechtlichen Maßnahmen zu tun hat und auch da wird nicht von Drogen gesprochen also ist unbelegt und von daher brauchen wir das.
Ja und dann gabs noch ein etwas längeres Feedback von Rübezahl.
Oh das bezog sich auf ja freie Rede freedom of speech und die ganze Diskussion um Alex Jones und ob er denn nun zurecht von Plattformen verbannt wird oder nicht.
Ich das einfach mal vor das ist schön geschrieben im US-amerikanischen Kulturraum genießt das Recht auf freie Rede Klammern freedom of speech,
einen extrem hohen Grundrechte Rang,
und es mit dem ersten Verfassungszusatz der Bill of Rights eine der zentralen Errungenschaften die der Visionär James Madison der Welt in den 1780 er geschenkt hat,
übrigens neben ein paar ganz anderen passablen Ideen beispielsweise dem Konzept der Gewaltenteilung hint executif exekutiver Eigenverantwortung,
der ganze erste Verfassungszusatz ist ein Werkzeug der Lippe Notierung der Macht der Bundesregierungen dient,
jetzt ist es so dass wir in Deutschland in unserem Grundgesetz das Konzept der freien Rede explizit nicht haben sondern eine abgewandelte Form,
nimmst das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung dieser Unterschied zeigt sich bereits in der Weimarer Reichsverfassung von 1919,
418 der bereits die Rede von dem Recht seine Meinung zu äußern verbrieft wurde.
Warum reite ich so auf diesem Begrifflichkeiten herum na eben weil sie sehr relevant für unsere heutige Diskussion sind das Recht eine Meinung zu äußern ist ein anderes als das Recht auf freie Rede nämlich insofern,
das ist besondere falsche Tatsachenbehauptung eben keine Meinung.
Nach dem kleinen aber wie ich finde notwendigen Exkurs komme ich zu meinem Argument freie Rede hat vielleicht 1780 gut funktioniert sie hat ziemlich sicher auch 1950 noch wunderbar ihre Funktion erfüllt,
wir haben ihr gerade in den offenen Gesellschaften des Westens viel zu verdanken,
die heute üblichen zentralisierten werbe Ertrags optimierten Publikationsformen wie beispielsweise Facebook welche die Problematik des informations overkill's,
sowie die Ertrags getriebene Verweildauer Optimierung durch ein maschinell vorsortiert das Informationsangebot zu lösen versuchen sind im Ergebnis nur in einem wirklich richtig gut,
sie bauen eine fürchterlich effektive Echokammer der dümmlichen leicht konsumierbar and Argumente und Thesen.
Das Konzept der freien Rede ist im derzeitigen Zustand unserer Kommunikationsgesellschaft,
eine üble Falle für die offene Gesellschaft und den Wettbewerb um die besten Ideen und Konzepte und in letzter Konsequenz für Wahlen und Demokratie insgesamt,
hinzu kommt dass in diesen verkorksten Gesamtumstände neben auch die traditionelle Gegenrede counters Beach nicht mehr funktioniert,
jetzt ist es natürlich nicht so dass Facebook Apple und Co der Staat wehren und eine Abwesenheit von Zensur auf ihrem Plattform garantieren müssten,
diesen ich nenne das der Einfachheit halber mal vor gesetzlichen Raum wird es nur problematisch wenn es so gestalten wie Alex Jones verwehrt werden würde IP space oder Domains und eigene Server zu betreiben,
deshalb ist das Argument für Netzneutralität und gegen Monopolbildung jenischer Infrastruktur ihre Nummer 11.
Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz bekannten und von euch ja auch diskutierten Schwächen nämlich eben die Anwendung des bestehenden Rechts also eben nicht das Recht auf freie Rede sondern auf meiner.
Ansatz 2 die verkorkste Kommunikationsinfrastruktur unserer Zeit auf eine dezentrale Basis umstellen,
der eben Profit.
Ich würde dafür plädieren beides zu tun aber Ansatz I also netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz nur für die kaputten Infrastrukturen Hans-Uwe anwenden lustigerweise ist dies genau im netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz abgebildet,
trifft aber nur auf Plattform von mehr als zwei Millionen Nutzern für Ansatz 2,
fehlt leider aktuell die Erkenntnis und der Wille auch ganz global hier helfen vermutlich technische Lösung am schnellsten zur Not gilt es hier doch nicht vor dem Verbot von demokratiefeindliche Geschäftsmodellen zurück zu schrecken.
In der analogen Welt haben wir übrigens eine Lösung für Ansatz zwei nämlich den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk,
ebenfalls als direkte Konsequenz aus den Dreißigern da mit der thematische Zirkelschluss auch für den Podcast und die Diskussion hier nun erbracht und ich belasse es.
Abends elang solche ausführlichen.
Wohl formulierten pipex mögen werden.
Dann ist mir das auch mal wenn auch hier minimal gekürzt in der Sendung so würdigen.
Genau um bevor da gleich wieder drauf eingegangen wird hier meint ja Ansatz zwei also zwei sagte ja dezent comunica verkorkste Kommunikationsinfrastruktur auf dezentrale Basis umstellen also öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk,
damit meint er das wahrscheinlich nicht aber das Profitstreben nicht die Aufmerksamkeit steuert das ist das was der Öffentlich Rundfunk auch unserer Meinung nach auspacken.
Da gab's noch ein Anna und Kommentar der so ein bisschen darauf eingehen also.
Basilic dieses Argument für ein Prinzip zu der der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk,
würde selten oder nicht mit das Besondere Tagesschau oder so
Themen setzen mit denen sich die Politik gerade nicht auseinandersetzt also sowas wie wann berichtet der öffentliche Rundfunk über die was weiß ich Probleme in der Hartz IV Gesetzgebung oder so.
Und kritisierte quasi die mangelnde investigativ und,
initiativ Tätigkeit des öffentlichen Rundfunk das wäre sehr interessant weil ich heute vor dieser Sendung kurz mit einem Journalisten sprach der bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
tätig ist und mich zu einem Interview
im Rahmen eines Interviews Frage stellte und ganz unabhängig davon sagte na ja wir wir sind ja spezifisch vom Credo her setzen wir keine Agenda wir betreiben nicht
Politik denn das ist ja eigentlich das was ein ob das gut ist oder nicht sehr sauer auf dem anderen Blatt aber wenn,
ein sadistisches Medium,
hingeht und ein Thema setzt vorantreibt lernen also sowas wie die Bild-Zeitung jeden Tag macht oder wie es auch um positives Beispiel zu nennen was wie netzpolitik.org macht oder.
Oder was ist was ist sonst noch so gibt ne also spezifisch investigativ arbeiten
Thema recherchieren Thema setzen Thema platzieren in der Öffentlichkeit und dem eine politische einen politischen Anstrich geben,
um im Zweifelsfall in letzter Instanz die Öffentlichkeit in eine Richtung zu bewegen,
nimm mir Hartz4 nehmen wir irgendwas in der Netzpolitik dann wäre der Vorwurf umso schwerwiegender.
Gegen einen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk man stelle sich vor die saßen da und würden sich irgendwie in der Tagesschau Redaktion überlegen was ist kanalisieren wir heute um die Welt,
so zu gestalten wie wir sie gerne hätten ja uns unsere Pensionsansprüche sind ich hoch genug lass uns mal ein paar,
lass uns mal ein paar am Hungertuch neigende alte Kollegen in ihren 20 Quadratmeter Wohnung besuchen und irgendwie in der Tagesschau darüber berichten,
wie schlecht ist uns geht also jetzt als böses Beispiel wäre der Vorwurf gegen den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk nur umso schlimmer.
Insofern spezifisch das ist nicht deren primäre Aufgabe und da kam jetzt, streiten ob man das will oder nicht ich,
habe aber auch
man merkt bei Meiningen einigen Diskussionsteilnehmer nicht argumentiert dass dass das einzige Medium ist was man konsumieren sollte sondern dass es ein wichtiges ist in einer Reihe an Medien die man konsumieren muss um sich ein,
vernünftigen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Ja einen vernünftigen Überblick wollte sich ja auch die Polizei verschaffen als sie.
Mg20c.
Genau in Hamburg wo wir ausführlich drüber berichtet haben auch wenn wir selber beide nicht vor Ort waren.
Wir haben drüber berichtet werden hier jemanden zu Gast in der G20 Folge,
habe ich viel über die polizeilichen Maßnahmen in diesem Rahmen gesprochen und insbesondere eine Maßnahme war da die Stich da Starter besonders ins Auge.
Denn die Polizei hat ja dann öffentlich dazu aufgerufen das an ihnen irgendwie Videomaterial hochladen soll
auf eine Plattform zusätzlich zu den ganzen Videomaterial was die Polizei ja selber auch die ganze Zeit an fertig ne überall wo du nen größeren
größere Ansammlung von Polizisten hat hast du auch diese Filme dabei,
und so hat die Sie die Hamburger Polizei sich jetzt vor der Situation dass sie insgesamt 17 Terabyte an Bild und Videomaterial haben und dieses Bild und Videomaterial unterziehen sie jetzt einer automatisierten Gesichtserkennung.
Und jetzt diese G20 Geschichte war ja vor etwas über einem Jahr seit einem Jahr arbeiten die jetzt da irgendwie dran und bisher hat diese gloriose Software,
insgesamt 3 in Worten drei Personen identifizieren können geile Software,
Tilman Meyn,
das unbedingt ausbauen ja auf dem 17. bei Bildern drei Personen zu identifizieren das ist wirklich eine grandiose Leistung in einem Jahr ich glaube wenn man das irgendwie an paar Ein-Euro-Jobber ausgelagert hätten wir schneller hingekriegt bei sehr viel
geringeren Kosten.
Und dann habe ich mich mal ein bisschen mit dieser Software auseinandergesetzt dann also abgesehen davon dass aufgrund dieses durchbrechen bahnbrechenden Erfolges das,
Zimmer dieser konsequente Einsatz von Video erkennungs Gesichtserkennungssoftware jetzt schon ein heißer Kandidat für das auch in Hamburg kommende neue Polizeigesetz sein wird.
Weil ich da mal mit dieser mit diesem Unternehmen auseinander übersetzer Unternehmen videmo,
eine Unternehmen aus Karlsruhe wo ich dachte ab Karlsruhe das ist doch echt krass Karlsruhe ist doch die Stadt in der schon 2011 im Stadion des KSC,
Essen mit Gesichtserkennungssoftware experimentiert wurde,
damals sahen die Fangemeinschaft ist kitekite Seat sich dagegen hat sich dagegen gewehrt und damals liegt das noch unter Schirmherrschaft des KIT
Karlsruher Institut für Technologie relativ renommiertes Informatik Institut in deutschen Landen als jeder Tag kann doch kein Zufall sein und nein es ist auch kein Zufall denn
dieses Unternehmen videmo.
Ist eine Ausgründung des KIT und pflegt leibeigen laut eigener Aussage seit vielen Jahren den Austausch mit dem kitee und kooperativ operiert intensiv mit dem Institut für Andro,
Chromatik der Fakultät für Informatik,
und das ist dann habe ich noch weiter geschaut die werden also die werden als einen eines der Erfolgsunternehmen der Kalte sky.de dadurch alle LPR,
Publikationen des KIT gescheucht,
nach einer Aussage nach eigener Aussage bereits ca 2006 als meine Mitgründer noch promovierten haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht wie wir mit Bezug zu unseren Forschungsthemen,
eigenes Unternehmen gründen könnten mit Hilfe einer Beratungsfirma führt wir dann eine Marktstudie durch um aussichtsreiche Produkt
und Dienstleistungen zu identifizieren hierbei lernen wir auch unsere ersten Kunden kennen das ist doch schön wenn so unsere Bildungs Gelder und Steuergelder verballert werden gleichzeitig hat dieses Unternehmen videmo,
aktuell oder in seiner Vergangenheit insgesamt auf ihrer Webseite gelistet 6 vom BMBF geförderte Projekte BMBF Bundesministerium für Bundesministerium bundesministerium.
Bundesministerium.
Bundesministerium für Bildung und Frauen fördert also indirekt sechs Projekten dieses Unternehmen es kooperiert mit dem kitee und Fraunhofer und,
ist eine kalte Ausgründung ist doch sehr schön wenn man hier tatsächlich mal zwischen Bildung und Forschung und Wirtschaft,
zona Verbindungen hat das der Unternehmenssitz ist auch irgendwie ein Block Weg vom guide.de.
Tja Karlsruhe das Silicon-Valley am Rhein.
Das Silicon Valley in Deutschland muss ja auch lang also das Silicon Valley in Deutschland wartet ja immer noch auf seine Entdeckung,
Ja und seine seine Geburtsstunde und das ist uns der Themen Überleitung timble kannst du einen shoutout Trolli Hagenow.
Ernsthaft war.
Tumtum Digitalisierung in Deutschland nun Vorschub zu leisten hat sich Angela Merkel entschieden.
Dass sie immer mal wieder auch Rat von außen suchen müssen,
Zitat ich bin überzeugt dass wir insgesamt in unserem Regierungshandeln nur dann mithalten können wenn wir uns auch immer wieder Rad von außen suchen.
Und sie möchte sich zu diesem Zweck einen digitalrat ins Leben rufen dieser digitalrat,
Wer wird ein schlagkräftiges Gremium mit zehn Experten aus der Praxis sein die uns antreiben die uns unbequeme Fragen stellen,
hat einer Merkel angekündigt und ich wurde auch über Twitter dann direkt darauf hingewiesen und habe dann gedacht also ich habe dann begonnen so meine Bewerbungsunterlagen zusammenzustellen
sie darauf hinzuweisen dass sie ja auch schon immer wieder sehr geehrte Frau merk ich war stets bemüht von außen rad an sie heran zu tragen im Rahmen ihres Regierungshandeln in verschiedenen Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestages.
Was auch dazu geschrieben dass du lange Hosen trägst in der Regel.
Ich habe geschrieben dass ich lange Hosen trage und Superman allenfalls Unterwäsche,
und Arbeit.
Die Bilder gehen jetzt nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Ich hatte meine Bewerbungsunterlagen noch nicht fertig da wurde dann schon die Auswahl für den Detailgrad bekannt gegeben,
war also gar nicht,
so dass ich dass man hier jetzt suchte man hatte sich offenbar schon entschieden wer denn nun die unbequemen Fragen an die Bundesregierung stellen soll in.
Zwei Sitzungen pro Jahr also zweimal pro Jahr digitaler.
Unbequemer Rad von außen.
Ich bin natürlich ein bisschen enttäuscht dass ich hier nicht die Gelegenheit hatte daran mitzuwirken unbequemen Fragen hätte ich auf jeden Fall ein paar gehabt aber,
wir freuen uns jetzt diese 10 Vertreterinnen und Vertreter in dieser,
in diesem Gremium zu sehen und ich weiß noch nicht mal ob ich so ob ich da jetzt so dauerhaft so traurig bin dass der Chaos Computer Club und eigentlich auch keine andere.
Dangelmaier zivilgesellschaftliche unabhängige Interessenvertretung in dieser Gruppe ist wir haben ja hier auch gesehen.
Wie,
haben eine Sendung darüber gemacht mit Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club wie die Internet die Enquete-Kommission Internet und digitale Gesellschaft über Jahre vom Bundestag zerrieben wurde.
Wir haben auch gesehen oder ich habe am eigenen Leib erfahren mit ich weiß nicht wie viele Stellungnahmen an Ausschüsse des Deutschen Bundestag ich inzwischen verfasst habe irgendwo zwischen 5 Uhr und 7 Uhr keine Ahnung habe ich hier auf jeden Fall ein Podcast glaube ich jedesmal erzählt.
Da habe ich ja auch jetzt nicht die Erfahrung gemacht dass man da jetzt unbedingt auf rad von außen und unbequeme Fragen besonders.
Anerkennend oder positiv reagiert hat das ist kein Geheimnis dass,
bis jetzt auch gar nicht nichts Besonderes habe ich jetzt nicht alleine das in der Regel auf meine unbequemen Fragen und meine Expertise hier keine Konten,
ich kann die Konsequenzen hatten wenn ich mich an den Deutschen Bundestag gewendet habe da sie haben Konsequenzen dafür die öffentliche Debatte ganz klar,
ist einer der Gründe warum ich das Theater auch immer noch mitmache und mich auch in diesem digitalrat wäre ich selbstverständlich
erinner eingetreten ich bin aber natürlich trotzdem nach einigen Jahren der Erfahrung dann doch sehr überrascht,
ja das wenn man sich da.
Über viele Jahre und Jahrzehnte engagiert nun 2018 die Bundeskanzlerin ernsthaft Sachen Amrum müsste sich Rat von außen holen ja während wir den ja nun wirklich
eigenfinanziert oder vielleicht auch einfach mal um ehrlich zu sein nicht finanziert.
Im Fall ist Chaos Computer Club seit über 30 Jahren versuchen wir waren stets bemüht,
diesen Rat an die Bundesregierung heranzutreten ob nun also dieser digitale hat das Ruder rumreißen wird und wie Ingo dachwitz bei netbet ecoark schreibt die verkorkste Netzpolitik von Angela Merkel,
irgendwie noch mal retten wird weiß ich nicht ich wünsche den Damen und Herren viel Glück,
sewenig Veranlassung da jetzt die einzelnen Mitglieder hinsichtlich ihrer Eignung oder politischen Ausrichtung zu beurteilen.
Und ich sehe wenig Grund dass jetzt im im Detail zu sagen ok das wird nichts mit denen oder das wird was mit denen oder der derjenige Vertreter ist gut oder diejenige Vertreterin ist besser,
oder diejenige Vertreter dann hätte da auch noch rein gehört Warum 10 Uhr und nicht 11 Uhr Mann hätte das ja echt auch einfach mal leise wenn man was richtig ernst meint ne.
Wenn man eine ungerade Zahl haben.
Gütersloh bis 10 Uhr.
Medeco aktuelle.
Da ist doch schon wieder ne da siehst du einfach.
Da fehlt mal wieder so der Mut.
Ja da fehlt der Mut genau.
Müsste bis 11 Uhr gehen.
Musst du bis 11 Uhr gehen tja.
Aber.
The digitalrat geht nicht bis 11 Uhr also ja,
ich verstehe deinen dein Wehklagen und ich bedauere das auch zu tiefstes und nicht zum zudem digitalwrite überhaupt rufen bis man in Österreich würde das ja sofort als Titel durchgehend ne.
Österreich genau in Österreich wäre ich.
Na der Held digitalrat das ist ja schön dass Sie mal vorbeischaut wir haben da an digitales Problem da können zumal.
Digital hat hat entschieden.
Na und.
Jeder einfach voran auch wenn ich bestimmt werden würde werde von unseren österreichischen hören dass ich nicht sagen bin und nicht müsste reichen da wieder löschen Dialekt nachzumachen candy.
Aber mir egal das ja also ich war so ein bisschen überrascht ehrlich gesagt ich habe das nicht kommen sehen das ist ja glaube ich schon länger standest stand sogar im Koalitionsvertrag.
Stimmt es dass ein solcher rad gebildet werden soll mir war so ja na ja gut also ich meine mich haut das jetzt nicht oben Weiligmann das ist halt wieder so eine so eine Mischung aus.
Professor Ada Begleitung und Unternehmertum ich weiß nicht so richtig was jetzt hier eigentlich groß beschlossen werden könnte ja also hier was was soll hier geschehen die treffen sich zweimal im Jahr.
Dann sagen die naja und könnte ja mal diesmal könnt ja mal das machen.
Aber das hat doch alles überhaupt gar keinen politischen Suport und ich freue mich halt auch was an dich um 20:18 Uhr noch groß diskutiert und beschlossen werden soll,
natürlich kann man sich jetzt irgendwie über die Bedeutung von KIZ unterhalten so oder warum irgendwie 20 x Bosch eine Koalition Vertrag drin steht,
aber nicht so oft Freiheit oder sowas nur das ist das Kernproblem werden sie oft genug Beklagten ist das halt einfach dem die Mangel Verbreitung von Daten Elchen in Deutschland und daran hängt einfach schonmal,
nahezu alles wird dich an.
Ist natürlich auch ein Kopfproblem aber ich glaube halt nicht dass man durch diese Auslagerung das erreicht ja warum sind diese Leute nicht einfach Minister für digitales.
Weißt du wenn wenn wenn man da jetzt,
man könnte diesen Rat eine wirtschaftliche Prägung unterstellen,
wenn man das täten,
dann könnte man aber umso eher von diesem rad erwarten dass sich dort DD die Idee durchsetzt das digitale Infrastruktur vielleicht helfen würde insofern ich
finde das wirklich nicht sinnvoll die jetzt irgendwie,
vorher zu verurteilen oder so ne oder deren der die einer Gesinnungsprüfung zu unterziehen und zu sagen das glauben wir nicht dass dass ihr da weiter kommt oder geht das nicht tun werdet ja vielleicht sorgen Sie für einen
sinnvolle Regulierung des Telekommunikationsmarktes das ist alles denkbar das wäre ja auch im wirtschaftlichen Interesse Deutschlands kann alles machen oder nicht.
Natürlich kann das alles sein aber ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau,
was jetzt noch noch ein Gremium was irgendwann mal Tag da jetzt noch gross reisen soll die Entscheidung stehen jetzt an standen schon längst an so die kann man die kann man auch öffentlich debattieren,
bunte das ist doch einfach nur Ausdruck fortgeschritten Hilflosigkeit,
man muss einfach Experten in die Exekutive bringen.
Wie war noch mal du hast das sehr häufig zitiert wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt Grill.
So ein Arbeitskreis.
Ach ja weiße und wenn es dann einfach für die zehn Vertreterinnen und Vertreter jetzt eine große Ehre ist und ihrer Karriere die nicht da ist auch schön.
Können sich jetzt digital raten Herren Frottee.
Kann sich eine Visitenkarte drucken Amerika.
Dann auf den Wiener.
Wird auf Gitarre.
Widerruf bei gehen.
Also ja es ist halt so weit so weit ist es mit uns gekommen das ist es ist wie gesagt ich bin gespannt was daraus wird jeder immerhin scheint Angela Merkel hier ein Problem erkannt zu haben,
ich bin da gar nicht so.
Ja also sie möchte sie möchte ja gerne von dem digitalwrite angetrieben werden und Diggi unbequeme Fragen kommen also Unterseite auch.
Wetter sicherlich stellen.
Ja jetzt vielleicht leichter haben können jetzt Haarverlust Bundespolitik hören,
auf jeden Fall ausreichend bequeme Fragen am Start.
Füllmenge digital radfahr Angela Merkel.
Haben wir denken sie gut gebrauchen.
Gleiche Woche,
wunderschöne Bekanntgabe als werde ich habe gerade auch im im Interview zu diesem Thema noch gesagt so wenn wir denke ich einige Digitalisierung in Deutschland dann können wir eigentlich die gesamte digital Poly,
Deutschland so zusammenfassen dass sie uns um alle Vorteile der Digitalisierung gebracht hat und uns,
alle Nachteile der Digitalisierung auf jeden Fall verstärkt hat.
Oder mindestens Erhalt.
Mindestens erhalten ja also wir haben keine Vorteile der Digitalisierung darf er aber auf jeden Fall alle Nachteile,
so würde ich die digitalpolitik der Bundesregierung zusammenfassen und das wurde selbstverständlich auch von Horst Seehofer
und Ursula von der Leyen gehört die nun in dieser Woche ihren Plan verfolgen wollen eine,
Agentur für Innovation in the cybersicherheit zu gründen.
Die also vom Bundeskabinett noch in dieser Woche beschlossen werden soll eigentlich gestern ich habe keine Nachrichten weiter darüber gefunden und diese Agentur soll zum Ziel haben,
sicherzustellen dass die Bundeswehr,
und die Sicherheitsbehörden im Kampf gegen Cyberangriffe die Innovationsführerschaft bei Schlüsseltechnologien behalten und Tools zur Analyse.
Oder zum virtuellen Gegenschlag nicht erst vom freien Markt einkaufen müssen was hören wir da also erstens,
die die also die Innovationsführerschaft behalten ich glaube da können wir,
erstmal laut lachen die hat Deutschland mit Sicherheit nicht das ist eine Sache die haben wir mit Sicherheit nicht.
Seidemann redet von bestimmten deutschen Technologien die international Anwendung finden den immer wieder Schwachstellen nachgesagt werden da könnte man auf jeden Fall noch von der Innovationsführerschaft Deutschlands,
reden aber ansonsten denke ich ist die hier einfach nicht vertreten gehen wir also zum zweiten
puls zum virtuellen Gegenschlag nicht erst vom freien Markt einkaufen,
ja ich stell mir also ich stell mir das immer wieder vor dass die da sitzen also wir haben hier was was ich noch GTA trifft,
was weiß ich die Wasserwerke in Deutschland ja die Infrastruktur steht,
Kopf LSD im Trinkwasser und
dann geht einer Lust mit dem Säcke Bitcoin und kauft sich auf dem freien Markt mit anderen Worten im Darknet herzu Gegenschlag so suche dringend Zauberwaffe,
Kaliber 9 oder sowas ne total also wir sehen dass sie jetzt in ihrer gesamten Hack und Back.
Rhetorik immer näher an den.com den ich ja hier schon seit Jahren prognostiziere dass sie nämlich,
Tools für dass sie Angriff Tools brauchen und zwar jetzt und nicht erst wenn es spät genug wenn es zuspät ist ne man merkt die Rhetorik wandert immer mehr dahin dass man aktive anderes Kapazitäten aufbauen muss und ich habe schon,
sehr häufig hier ausgeführt es wird nicht so sein dass wenn man irgendwie,
Bensheimer Gegenschlag ist das gesagt wird los Männern an die Tastatur jetzt Hacker.
Es geht nur so dass man sich vorher in den jeweiligen,
Infrastrukturen und sonstigen anderes Ziel herumtreibt diese vorher infiltriert und im Falle eines Gegenschlag dann eine Infektion ausweitet zu einer was was ich dauert Hase.
Und das geht das nicht und da geht die Reise hin,
ich bin gespannt was der digitalrat zu diesen Plänen sagt das hier eine weitere Institution der der Exekutive geschaffen werden soll deren Ziel nicht,
das Bauen von IP Sicherheit ist sondern dass,
ja mir ist auch nicht ganz klar wie das Verhältnis zwischen der Agentur für Innovation in der cybersicherheit und der Zentralstelle für Informationen,
Aman das kriege ich nie hin ich kriege es nie hin lieber Tim,
zitis zitiste zitis ist die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich ja also das ist wieder so richtig geil deutsch.
Ich würde mir ich wäre gespannt ob vielleicht sich in unter den Digital Rethen,
Herr jemand befindet der dann vielleicht sagt lass uns mal überlegen ob wir uns aus diesem Hexenkessel irgendwie raushalten können vielleicht schaffen wir es vielleicht sogar am KIT.
Mal eine stringente.
Codebasis für ihren wieso IP Sicherheit zu schaffen.
Zum Schutz von digitalen Infrastrukturen oder hast du nicht gesehen Komplexitätsreduktion und irgendwie Schutz,
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger Sicherstellung der Integrität der informationsverarbeitende Systeme solche Ideen.
Das wäre schon wirklich spannend denn ich sehe hier für Deutschland wirklich einfach keine ich sehe da keine Schnitte ich sehe da wirklich keine,
Schnitte zu holen und ich halte das eben für grundsätzlich den falschen Ansatz in offensiv Kapazitäten zu investieren egal ob es dabei um den Timer geht oder um,
die direkte Tötung mit Explosionen und ich glaube das hier in der Verteidigung.
Also mit andern Worten dem Aufbau sicherer Infrastruktur den auch Versicherer Systeme vielmehr.
Zu holen wäre,
das ist dieses ganze Aufbauen von offensiv Kapazitäten ist die Kapitulation nichts anderes als die Kapitulation vor dem Anspruch seinen eigenen Scheiß in den Griff zu kriegen.
Das finde ich es eine schöne zusammen, irgendwie auch durchaus mal betonen werden es ja nun mehrfach diskutiert,
Angriff heißt im Prinzip Unsicherheit bewahren ja Infrastruktur angreifbar halten damit Lücken ausgenutzt werden kann selber machen sind nicht irgendwelche digitalen
Beschleuniger dimano wo drauf hält und wenn man mehr davon hat dann knallt auf der anderen Seite mehr als bei einem selbst das ist überhaupt also dieser Begriff Zauberwaffe Pass einfach gar nicht,
das ganze nur das Erhalten von Unsicherheit in der Infrastruktur ist die man dann ausnutzt aber um sie ausnutzen zu können
im Prinzip schon ein vollkommen kontraproduktives Netzwerk von versteckten so
fuzzy agente da feindes Linien bereithalten und das wird einfach irgendwohin führen außer halten die totale Kapitulation,
der gesamten Infrastruktur na ja gut aber das war ja nur eh schon gut aufgestellten dem Bereich von daher passt das.
Das ist jetzt verstehe ich das endlich das ist die digitale Verteidigungslinie der Bundesregierung ihr wollt unsere digitale Infrastruktur kaputtmachen welche.
Java einfach gar keine Bett.
Packet.
Ach ja.
So du hast leider über ein Thema drüber gestreut dass er den scroll musste noch mal und hin und nee oder.
Nee habe ich nicht.
Ich habe über sorry ich habe von Thema weg.
Das muss man noch mal üben.
Ja das muss ich echt noch mal üben das nicht an diesem natural scrolling.
Wo wo ja wir brauchen noch eine weitere Alternative.
Simone Alternative für Maßen langsam mal.
Wir hatten das ja schon dass Herr Maaßen sich mit der AFD Vorsitzenden Frau Petry getroffen hat wie berichtet wurde.
Wie berichtet von der letzten Woche und da gab es jetzt ein der FDP-Abgeordnete Benjamin Strasser hat eine Anfrage an,
das vermutlich Innenministerium gestellt dass wir für den für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz,
tätig ist denn er gauland hatte irgendwie in einem Interview von sich gegeben Herr Maaßen hat mir nach einer also er habe sich mit dem,
Herr Maaßen getroffene Verfassungsschutz Chef Maßen getroffen um über den Verdacht zu sprechen es gäbe einen russischen Einfluss Agenten.
In der afd-bundestagsfraktion und gauland sagte dann,
Herr Maaßen hat mir nach einer gewissen Prüfung gesagt dass da nichts dran ist ja und daraufhin hat der
der FDP-Abgeordnete Benjamin Strasser sich eben andersherum gewandt und gefragt was war da los
und der Vorgang wird mehr oder weniger bestätigt und das hat es hatte ich auch ein Problem denn es gibt ein übliches Verfahren für solche
Überprüfung will wäre es auch für mehr Deutschland irgendetwas nicht geregelt hätten es gibt nämlich ein sicherheitsüberprüfungsgesetz und an dieses Verfahren hat sich Herr Maaßen hier nicht geheilt,
indem er sich eben mit gauland irgendwo
betrifft und gauland sich Mitglied gauland eben wieder unterhält wie hier Prüfungen vorgenommen werden und sich darüber offenbar diese
informell.
Also Prüfungen dem Fall von einzelnen Personen der.
Außerdem hat er sich dann noch im Juni 2018 mit dem Stefan Brandner getroffen Stephan Brandner wenn ich mich nicht täusche ist der mit der Machete.
Das ist der der irgendwie besoffen zu Hause saß und das dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit mit seiner Pakete per Drohnen wollte.
Ja Brandner mit dt glaube ich sind die Duck Duck go ja genau,
was hatte der irgendwie so eine das Waffe einfach so eine Alibaba Säbeln irgendwie auf jeden Fall keine abendländische Machete die der da hatte er sah er aus wie.
Sonnar t Logo.
Tausendundeine Geschichten aus dem Morgenland.
Ja mit dem hat er sich auch getroffen das ist ja eh und da sprach er der ist ja im Rechtsausschuss er ist ja sogar Vorsitzer des Rechtsausschusses war es ja auch irgendwie so eine.
Auch so ihr wie was ist wo ich habe fürchte dass ich unter Umständen in dieser Legislaturperiode vielleicht noch mal hin müsste und ich weiß gar nicht ob ich da mit so einer Machete reinkomme weil,
Heidi will ich auf jeden Fall mitnehmen zur für eine Anhörung und die dann daneben meinen glasbier stellen wollen.
Geht wahrscheinlich gar nicht mit dem hat er sich über dessen Funktion als Vorsitz des Rechtsausschusses unterhalten.
Und das ist ja wieder ein Witz der Rechtsausschuss ist ja überhaupt nicht für den Verfassungsschutz,
zuständig das wäre der Innenausschuss gleichzeitig gehen im Rechtsausschuss natürlich,
Gesetze über den Tisch die die Interessen,
des Verfassungsschutzes berühren sei es nur solche Ideen wie die Regelung von Staatstrojaner einsetzen.
Und so weiter ich bin,
ich meine man kann diesen Maßen nicht verbieten sich mit Politikern zu unterhalten aber die Themen und Vorgänger sind da schon durchaus interessant,
und vor allem was immer wieder,
was sind diesem Rahmen gar nicht so beleuchtet wird letzte Woche sparen wir über den Vorwurf dass er Frauke Petry Tipps gegeben habe wie eine Beobachtung der AFD durch den Verfassungsschutz zu entgehen sei.
Und es ist nun nicht so als hätten nicht mehrere Land Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz die AFD wegen ihrer Kontakte zu ganz klar verfassungsfeindlichen Organisationen beobachten wollen.
Insbesonder hat sogar Bayern nicht unbedingt das Bundesland dem man dass man auf einer anderen,
Gala als sachsenforum führte beim anderen Ende der Skala Saxophon würde eine Analyse vorgelegt und sagte hey da müssen wir mal gucken das scheint uns hier nicht in Ordnung zu sein und Maaßen hat sich immer wieder,
gegen eine Beobachtung der AFD ausgesprochen das heißt sein,
seine er sein Handeln im Bereich der exekutiven Eigenverantwortung deckt sich hier mit denen.
Mit dem was man sich in der AFD ohnehin über ihn sagt.
Tatsächlich irgendwie langsam.
Nicht mehr so witzig ne wir dürfen vor dem Hintergrund nicht die.
Immer noch ungeklärten Probleme unterschiedlicher Vertreter der Landes und Bundesämter für Verfassungsschutz im NSU Skandal vergessen.
Und es ist sicherlich im Sondermaß.
Beunruhigend wenn sich überhaupt so ein Inlandsgeheimdienst in die Politik einmischt das hatte ich ja letzte Woche auch schon ausgeführt.
Und es ist enorm.
Besorgniserregend wenn dann auch noch hier relativ viel den Verdacht nährt vieles in die Richtung zeigt dass es hier auch noch eine Sympathie.
Dieses,
Verfassungsschutzes für die rechte Szene gibt und das sehen wir nicht zum ersten Mal ist jetzt nicht nur so dass man sagt achso ja hier bei Maßen da der hat sie jetzt zwar da mal mit der AFD getroffen das ist jetzt ein Skandal in 1 der ganze Laden ist ein Skandal seit,
und ist in ist in jedem Skandal den du irgendwo hast verwickelt massenüberwachung Deutschland diese gesamte NSU Geschichte wo die Woche nur die LKW-Ladung an Papier durch ihren Schredder gescheucht haben.
Und wo relativ klar ist dass die ihre Vertrauensleute irgendwie so ungefähr bei bei den beiden Uwes im im Wohnmobil sitzen hatten.
Und da wird mir echt langsam ein bisschen,
mulmig und das hat nichts damit zu tun dass wir generell narcoren gegen Geheimdienste hintun wir,
aber wir haben glaube ich auch in der letzten Sendung noch einmal betont dass wir,
ihn nicht die grundsätzliche das grundsätzliche Existenzrecht anzweifeln aber wenn wir hier eine,
dermaßen freidrehende Behörde mit diesen dann doch sehr weitreichenden Befugnissen für Grundrechtsverletzungen haben
und zum operieren ohne jegliche sinnvoll durchführbare Kontrolle sei sie parlamentarisch oder sonstiger Natur,
dann wird das echt langsam ein bisschen eng.
An der Stelle können wir auch noch mal auf das schöne Gespräch verweisen was wir über Logbuch ist billig 256 geführt haben.
Was damit glaube ich auch erstmal belassen.
Denn wir haben ja noch viel mehr wir haben ja.
Ein weiteres bundesministerium.
Ja wie heißt das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge flüchtlingsfragen oder was wofür steht BamS Nummer.
BAMF du meinst wofür es wirklich steht es steht für Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge Koreck.
Nissen weiß ich wusste ich mal was das BAMF also keines der Sonne ein Amt.
Hat ja auch das haben wir hier begleitet zur Bewältigung seiner Aufgaben,
in letzter Zeit einige Technologien und Kompetenzen dazu bekommen,
das ist einerseits diese Technologie zum Auslesen von mobiltelefon wenn er seine Person dort auftaucht die nicht in der Lage ist,
sich auszuweisen.
Was hat sich den Pass verloren hat als ihr Flucht Schiff von syrischen Küstenwache zerstochen wurde,
oder sowas ne dann soll so die Theorie sie.
Diese Person quasi ihr handy zum Auslesen geben und dann wird ein,
checke macht aufgrund was was ich der Metadaten und Location Daten die diesem Handy gespeichert sind ob die Geschichte diese Person erzählt über ihre Herkunft irgendwie.
Der Wahrheit entsprechen,
Wassertechnologie die sie haben ist vor allem eine Digitalisierung dieser Prüfung die üblicherweise durch Dolmetscher vorgenommen wird der wird dann eine,
Person bestellt die.
In der Region von dieser von der diese Person angibt dass Sie daher stammen würde besondere Kenntnis hat einerseits über die Sprachen und Dialekte die in der Region gesprochen werden andererseits auch von der Region selber,
und dann macht man im Prinzip solch wir wird so ein Fachgespräch geführt ne also wenn da jemand sagt ich komme aus Syrien ja dann wird also ein Thema angesprochen der der der der
Sprachen und Dialekte der Region mächtig ist der Sohn die sich da auskennt und die führt dann eben ein Gespräch
und sagt ja immer Wasser schieben wie war's denn da unter erinnerst du dich noch an dieses und jenes vorkommendes wie hast du denn da Wie heißen deine Kinder und Freunde und dann sollte man ja.
Denke ich tatsächlich dass es eine sehr sinnvolle Methode weil ich habe ja z.b. Tim merke ich ja auch sofort das III ist wenn ich nicht mit Internet.
Ja total.
Bin aber man also ich denke man kann in einem Gespräch über sein Herkunftsland.
Denn das Gespräch eine Stunde dauert im Zweifelsfall nicht sinnvoll jemand anderen davon überzeugen dass wir aus einem anderen Land ist halte ich für eine für eine relativ sinnvolle Methode.
Und das ist aber natürlich da braucht man ein Termin mit den Dolmetschern und so wie du muss jemand kommen der von Pisa,
der von dieser Region auch Ahnung hat und so weiter und auch da gibt's jetzt eine Analyse System was diesen Prozess automatisieren soll und das Verfahren läuft ungefähr so du kommst also kommst dann als Prüfung,
Gegenstand oder Prüfungs gegenständliche Person dorthin.
Und dann werden dir ein paar Bilder aus deinem Privatleben vor vor die Nase gelegt und ein Telefonhörer in die Hand gedrückt und dann musste die Person hier zwei Minuten,
über diese Bilder sprechen was da drin zu sehen ist sowas was ich hier ist meine hier sind wir meine Familie vor unserem Haus in so und so.
Und dann berechnet ein Computer.
Welche Sprache da wohl gesprochen wird was eigentlich ein kurzer Exkurs gar nicht so eine blöde Idee ist die DS erstmal gar nicht so blöd es gibt ich weiß nicht wie viele Sprachen auf dieser Welt und Dialekte,
und die unterscheiden sich im Zweifelsfall durch ihre durch ihre Phoneme,
also durch die kleinsten akustischen Einheiten aus denen die Sprache besteht und wenn du jetzt irgendwie vermutlich kannst du einen größeren Teil der Sprachen die auf diesem Planeten gesprochen werden,
da anhanddessen unterscheiden ich weiß nicht ob eine 2 Minuten Aufnahme reicht,
ich gehe davon aus dass du relativ viel Varianz innerhalb einer Sprache hast aber du kannst irgendwie dich auf Konsonanten und sowas irgendwie.
Geht GTA zu sagen die Frage ist ja was soll erkannt werden.
Genau die Gefahr erkannt werden soll welche Sprache spricht diese Person.
Dr Kant werden soll was ist die Herkunft.
Welche Sprache spricht diese Person.
Na ja im Sinne von was ist die eigentliche Herkunft also Sprache soll Anhaltspunkt für Herkunft sein diese soll ermittelt.
Genau also ist es natürlich jemand der in der Lage wäre eine Sprache Fleece eine eine andere Sprache fließend zu sprechen der kann dieses System im Zweifelsfall ganz gut,
umgehen was braucht man um ein solches System zu bauen wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen dass das,
dass das sinnvoll wäre also ich glaube ich glaube das tatsächlich dass es möglich ist etwas zu bauen das hatte ich schon im wunderschönen an oder eine wunderschönen kornack es gezeigt wenn also kann das System
erkennen dass hier gerade jemand der nicht jemand spricht der nicht,
die Muttersprache spricht also jemand der weiß dass ich ich spreche dort in Englisch rein kann das System im Zweifelsfall erkennen das war Englisch,
kann das Programm aber auch erkennen das war ein deutscher der versucht Englisch zu sprechen das wäre schon die nächste Herausforderung,
aber das System hat schon vorher ein Problem denn egal welche Sprache du damit erkennen möchtest,
das System muss diese Sprache überhaupt einmal kennen du brauchst also Unmengen an Audioaufnahmen in der Sprache in einer bestimmten Sprache in einem bestimmten Dialekt und was das Ding nicht alles unterscheiden soll,
damit das Teil überhaupt eine sichere Aussage treffen kann ja auch und Aussagen werden.
Hiram zumindest du berichtet ist Anna biselli.
Auch in der wissenschaftlich falschen.
Mutation gegeben denn dieses System in dem Fall den Anna hier schildert sagt der Computer die Person spreche Türkisch und zwar zu 63% mit anderen Worten das System war nicht in der Lage eine Aussage zu treffen.
Also 63 % Sicherheit also das System ist.
Also eine Aussage würde man Treffen mit die Sprache die hier gesprochen wird ist folgende und die Sicherheit mit der diese Aussage getroffen werden kann würde man sinnvollerweise in einem P Wert ausgeben und dieser p-Wert ist
sollte unter was weiß ich nur, 0.5 oder 0,01 liegen dass man sagt,
mit zu 99% ich bin mir zu 99% sicher bin ein dieses Ergebnis käme.
Sorry bei diesem Ergebnis wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir zu diesem Ergebnis kommen obwohl die Person nicht die Sprache spricht.
5 von 100 oder 1 von 100 ja das war irgendwie so also in einem von 100 Fällen würden wir dieses Ergebnis bekommen obwohl die Person nicht die Sprache spricht eine Aussage wie zu 63% spricht die Person türkisch ist,
einfach nicht also die ist noch nicht mal so dies ja nicht interpretierbar was ist denn mit den restlichen 47%,
A7 30%,
na das zitter also totaler Unsinn noch dazukommt also in diesem Beispiel Personen über die Diana hier berichtet die spricht den kurdischen Dialekt Sorani so jetzt wäre die Frage ist dieses System überhaupt in der Lage,
den kurdischen Dialekt Sorani zu erkennen ist das ein mögliches Ergebnis.
Überhaupt erstmal kurdisch Zeug.
Wäre ja also ich kann das System das überhaupt es gibt eine klare Dienstanweisung dass dieses System ohnehin nur zum Einsatz gebracht werden darf wenn die Person behauptet eine Sprache aus einer Region zu kommen deren,
Sprache dieses System überhaupt in der Lage ist zu erkennen was hier in diesem Fall offenbar noch nicht mal der der Fall war also dieses System kann gar nicht Sorani
erkennen.
Wohl aber der Dolmetscher bei dem die Person im Sommer 2016 einen Termin hatte gesagt die hier das ist der kurdische Dialekt Sorani da kommt die Person her und das hat die Person auch behauptet dass es konsistent mit Ihrer Schilderung und jetzt wird ein.
System was ganz offensichtlich ohnehin unsinnige aus unsinnige Aussagen trifft hier fehl angewendet und,
das mündet dann in einem,
in einer Ablehnung mündete hier in einer Ablehnung des Antrags dieser Person also wir haben ja einen nicht folgt nicht vollkommenes System.
Das also sehr starke Limitationen hat das außerhalb seines von den Entwicklern gesteckten anwendungsrahmen es verwendet wird und dann zu zu schweren.
Individuellen Konsequenzen führt und das ist kein Einzelfall wenn du Leuten.
Mein Computer hin stellst du irgendetwas Sack.
Wären sie das Urteil dieses Computers höher werden als das eigene insbesondere wenn dieser Computer ihn eine Unmenge an Arbeit spart,
da kannst du noch so dick dran schreiben 63% und jeder jeder Mensch der irgendwie grob des Rechnens,
fähig ist sagt okay das ist mit dem mit den restlichen Wahrscheinlichkeiten die hier eine Rolle spielt mit den restlichen prozentigen Rolle spielen könnten.
Ja also das wird immer noch mal kurz dieses Beispiel raus zu grafenwirt YUM Artikel dann auch noch berichtet,
dieses System diese Software hat die Wappen Namen was nicht kann keinen einzigen kurdischen Dialekte offiziell.
Hatte ich gerade schon gesagt.
Hattest du das gesagt.
Habe ich ausführlich dargestellt.
Und es gibt halt,
der A3 so ich habe mal gerade bei Google Translate geschaut Google große Firma mit 4 Ressourcen extrem unterwegs Sprachübersetzung Erkennen von Sprachen ist da ein echtes,
zum Ziel ganz ganz ganz wichtig um den eigentlichen Auftrag des dann nimmst du erfüllt der hat genau einen dieser kurdischen,
Dialekte oder A3 Sprachvarianten Dialektes trifft glaube ich an der Stelle überhaupt nicht es ist einfach haarsträubend dass dass man sich hier überhaupt auf so etwas verlassen möchte.
Also das System wird gerade schon sagte entgegen seiner überhaupt von den Herstellern,
benannten Eignung angewendet das kann nämlich nur irgendwelche also die die wenigen arabischen groß Dialekte unterscheiden das heißt es hätte hier überhaupt nicht zum Einsatz kommen dürfen.
Und selbst wenn es zum Einsatz kommt ist es ja fehlerbehaftet der stolpert noch nicht mal irgendjemand darüber sondern sortir hoedus musst du da gesprochen hast ist zu 63% türkisch,
ab geht's zu airberlin oder wer auch immer jetzt die,
die Abschiebung fliegt und das ist eben kein Einzelfall das wenn Systeme eine,
Entscheidungshilfe darstellen und inadäquat angewendet werden dass sie trotzdem angewendet werden das werden wir nicht nur beim BAMF sehen sondern das werden wir sehen wir auch an an vielen anderen Stellen wo,
an solchen insbesondere wenn ein solches System erlaubt,
sehr viel Zeit und Arbeit zu sparen und das ist diese dieses Problem der Algorithmen Gläubigkeit der mir eigentlich ein Lehrbuch Beispiel von man weiß nicht wie das System funktioniert.
Die Leute wissen können auch also das System trifft auch eine Aussage die nicht geeignet ist,
zur zur Beurteilung der Frage also man müsste immer,
quasi also man gibt einfach Wahrscheinlichkeiten sowieso nicht in Prozent an der mit 6 schon mal an und man muss eben die eigentlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit angeben dass das System,
falsch liegt das ist das wie man eine Aussage in Insel in ihrer Aussagekraft,
wissenschaftlich ausweist man sagt nicht der spricht zu 63% türkisch sondern in 100 solcher Fällen würden wir uns nur einmal in unserem Urteil täuschen und unser Urteil ist folgendes,
das wäre die richtige Aussage systemis von vorne sind kaputt,
und jetzt von Amateuren in Situation verwendet für die es noch nicht mal vorgesehene.
Da fällt mir wieder meinen Lieblingsfilm ein Brasilien vielleicht auch kennst.
Ich gehe davon aus dass du jetzt die gleich deine lange Schirmmütze aufsetzt und irgendwas aus der Wand reißt wie schon.
Film genau,
der Film dreht sich ja sozusagen also beginnt mit einem technischen Fehler eine Fliege fliegt in einen Drucker und druckt ein B-Stadt einen Tee daraufhin wird nicht Harry Shuttle festgenommen sein Harry Potter der daraufhin aufgrund dieser Umstände dieser
brutale Festnahme die danach stattfindet irgendwie verstirbt und später wird dann der
Hinterbliebenen Frau erläutert also das in der Akte von Harry hatte nicht über den Herzfehler von helmbarte drin stand ist ja schließlich nicht mal.
Wir verlassen uns hier nur auf die System.
Bitte Nachricht.
Dann haben wir jetzt kommen ja so langsam in den Bereich der der kürzeren Meldungen.
Sag das nur als vorsichtige Warnung Themen,
beantworten wir kommen jetzt zum Langenthal SPORTCARS gab jetzt in am Wochenende mal wieder eine Zusammenrottung von,
ja irgendwie Rene war nicht das Wochenende Anfang der Woche.
Hater Congress.
Ein Hater Kongress in dem kleinen Ort altschauerberg ja wo.
Ein Personen hier und Wohnort hat die sich und auf YouTube als Drachenlord ihren Namen gemacht hat und dort mit teilweise sehr kruden.
Ansichten sich an Ihren an ihre Fans und Hater wendet nämlich die meddl Leude.
Genau,
Brands genommen auf die Berichterstattung von Rayk anders sein Vorfall ist höchst bedauerlich aber noch lange nicht,
beendet das ganze ist jetzt soweit eskaliert das halt irgendwie Leute sich da einer Hundertschaft zusammenfindet was ich dann da irgendwie.
Sie haben eine sehr meine Demo sie haben eine Demo angemeldet manevi knapp 100 Leute die Demo trug den Titel dem Drachen das Fürchten lehren.
9700 Menschen hatten sich auf Facebook angekündigt ganz so viel sind aber nicht gekommen.
Die Polizei hat er irgendwie Platzverweise ausgesprochen und müssen dann die wie die Leute da irgendwie mit dem,
unterstützungskommando dem USK der bayerischen Polizei irgendwie in Schach halten.
Und M.
Dann kam auch die Hundestaffel zum Einsatz ganze Sachbeschädigungen und.
Prinz
schon jetzt hat Jan sich abspielt Leute die einfach manisch fixiert sind auf eine vollkommen im Internet vollkommen unbedeutende Person,
irgendwie sicherlich eine Menge Probleme hat aber sicherlich dich ein Problem für diese Gesellschaft darstellt aber weiß ja mal Spaß macht sich gegen Schwächere aufzuspielen,
gibt aber Leute die hier kein Halten kennen und Ermahnung sitzt müssen das jetzt für dich bis zum Ende spielen sich das zusamm Mob zusammen
Rotten on
um hier irgendwie eine Person die sowieso schon längst in die Ecke gedrängt ist das Leben noch weiter schwer zu machen und nebenbei auch noch mal den kompletten Dorf den damit verbundenen Familien Existenzen etc.pp und das ganze eskaliert total.
Das coole ist wenn man das Thema jetzt beeil dich mal wer mir dann auch regelmäßig,
Leute in unseren Kommentaren die offenbar mit solchen Aktionen sympathisieren oder auch mit den Leuten die,
für diese Zeit sich das erste Mal dass sowas stattfindet die da zum ersten Mal zu aufgerufen haben,
und diese Demonstration bezeichnet sich selbst als Mahnung an den Drachenlord aus dem Netz zu verschwinden.
Die betonen allerdings sie sein friedlich wollten ihm nichts Böses und äußert sich hoffentlich versteht er dieses Signal und hört auf das ist echt,
also das ist wirklich interessant,
muss dazu sagen der Typ hat sie gesagt einige Äußerungen in seinen Videos die sicherlich nicht unter,
Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland fallen hat er irgendwie auch mal sich irgendwie in irgendeinem video,
ich weiß nicht genau ob das sarkastisch oder ernst gemeint ist äußert das irgendwie ein Holocaust mal wieder ein Eis wäre oder sowas ich denke aber auch wenn man und dann will ich ihm jetzt auch nicht zu nah treten wenn man denen,
wenn man sich den mal 5 minuten anguckt merkt man das der.
Weil ich gar nicht mehr weiß wo.
Der zum also relativ eingeschränkte,
Informationsverarbeitung Möglichkeiten hat um das mal sehr vorsichtig auszudrücken er Mensch glaube ich.
Braucht wahrscheinlich Hilfe so in der in der Bewältigung.
Wird das allerletzte Mal schon festgehalten total.
Deine ist seines Lebens,
ist denke ich für viele für eine geordnete Teilnahme an der Gesellschaft,
gerade auch also in verschiedenen Bereichen nicht geeignet Sohn für sowas haben wir eigentlich soziale Sicherungssysteme,
solchen Menschen irgendwie die Möglichkeit geben sollen sich irgendwie,
einzubringen in der Gesellschaft gegenüber den auch zu unterstützen ich denke der fällt der auf jeden Fall rein umso tragischer ist es dass es hier offenbar Menschen gibt die entweder den ernst nehmen.
Was schonmal der Fehlernummer 1 ist denn wer hier nicht erkennt dass da ein Jahr.
Die gesagt in der Informationsverarbeitungskapazität stark eingeschränktes Individuum spricht und zweitens dann auch noch mein dass das jetzt irgendwie ein Problem wäre das die Aufmerksamkeit einer Demonstration.
Benötigt er hat offenbar dermaßen den Knall nicht gehört aber ich fahre mich sowieso immer wieder kleiner persönlicher Rand wenn ich in dieses Internet schaue für was für eine Scheiße ihr Zeit habt.
Was also ihr habt dieses wunderschöne Leben dieses schöne Internet und das ist das was ihr mit euch anfangen könnt.
Das ist das wofür ihr ein Tag eures Lebens verwendet euch mit dem Idioten auseinanderzusetzen und dann auch noch da in dieser in diesem Dorf
die Menschen und den den Menschen die da wohnen das Leben zur Hölle zu machen und das dermaßen auf die Spitze zu treiben dass dieses gesamte Dorf sich auch noch gegen den Bandit und das empfindet ihr dann auch noch als
Bestärkung eures tun und dann landet ihr den welchen Kommentarspalten und sagt ja hier wir sind aber hier was weiß ich die Speerspitze des antifaschistischen Widerstandes
gegen jeden Idioten der in jedem Dorf in Bayern Sitz wenn ihr diese Energie,
Mall in irgendeiner Form sinnvoll einsetzen würde die eucher offenbar antreibt,
es treibt euch heraus es gibt ja etwas gegen dass ihr euch wenden möchtet ja wenn auch mit ihm wie den völlig bescheuerten falschen Methoden aber wenn euch da mal was einfallen würde so dann will ich auch irgendwie mit ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung in die Welt blicken.
Ja ja ja auch schon einige einige Beispiele genannt wo man seine Energie sehr wohl drauf werfen kann auch mit Demonstration.
Ja wird es wenn auch diese Demonstration nicht zum Ziel haben sollten das irgendein Mensch aus dem Internet verschwindet habt ihr eigentlich mal festgestellt dass ihr bei YouTube einfach weiterklicken könnt das scheiß Internet ist echt groß und da ist eine Menge Mist drin.
Ja ich meine ihr habt das abonniert selber schuld also einfach nicht anschauen und fertig,
soll er doch irgendwie seine Freunde die mit ihm klar kommen die da um den gemeinsamen Film fahren und wir über Metal reden und fertig jokers nobody cares,
aber ja ja guter. An dieses,
diese Energie die habt und dass das Positive was er meint dazu kanalisieren auf Dinge zu verwenden die einfach diese Anstrengung nicht auch nur im Ansatz wert sind es ist einfach traurig,
und das sagt mir aber euch aus also irgendjemand den ihr da in den Fokus.
Die ganze Story ist es überhaupt nicht wird das überhaupt nicht wert hier überhaupt Kapitelmarken zu kriegen kriegt aber.
Teichfilter schon ein Phänomen des das Internet dass man auch mal betrachten sollte dann auch in seiner Breite.
Na also natürlich deswegen tun wir das ja auch so aber ich finde so absurd.
Dass wir uns über sowas überhaupt unterhalten müssen das dass ich an so etwas so was zeigt.
Sagst du immer so schön irgendwie great minds discuss ideas average minds discuss Events.
Kannst mal meins ist Gas Pieper habe ich nicht gesagt sondern ich glaube eleanor Roosevelt.
Misfits Simon.
Aber sehr schön muss man auch wissen dass das Internet schlägt zurück,
und zwar wurde mir hier ein Screenshot aus einer Webseite zugespielt,
t und hat einer onion Top-Level-Domain betrieben wird und.
Ganz offenbar in deutscher Sprache mit Inhalten und Themen hantiert die,
denke ich mal nicht legal sind jetzt ein Forenposts,
von mit dem Titel Jungs in Emskirchen von 20 bis 21 August diesen Monat findet ein Treffen in Emskirchen statt das ist ein Dorf in Bayern
lalala und ich werden dort sein Kurzerklärung zum Hintergrund ein Bekannter aus dem sowieso Forum hat mich auf ein großes Treffen von jungen an diesem Datum in Emskirchen aufmerksam gemacht es wird erwartet dass Sie mindestens 100 Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene
hinreisen werden um den Drachenlord ein Youtuber der dort lebt zutreffen das Schöne ist es werden praktisch nur Jungs rein,
die Reisen mindestens mit zwei Autos an ursprünglich war ein Wohnwagen geplant aber es ist unsicher um lalala das organisiert bekommt selbst mit den Autos haben wir aber noch Plätze frei deswegen wollte ich mal fragen ob er Lust hat,
mitzukommen den Apollo Ort besprechen wir dort noch bisher es geplant mit einem Grill mitzunehmen Schlafsäcke für den Fall der Fälle und reichlich Alkohol und die Jungs lockert.
Darf ich nicht sagen Freunde das ist halt Karatas ihr gerufen habt.
Hörtest das Karma dass ihr gerufen habt macht euch mal schön locker.
Gott Gott skip skip skip.
So du wolltest diese Sendung ganz schnell.
Zweite Seite Hintern.
Aber ihr seht so das Internet das Internet ist stets um das Karma bemüht.
Nun ja aber am Horizont sind wichtige Dinge unter anderem die rote Gefahr.
Die rote Gefahr.
Das FBI ermittelt einmal wieder wegen Angriffen auf US-Demokraten und konservative Trump Gegner,
jetzt kurz vor Beginn unserer Aufnahme wurde dann auch noch mal bestätigt dass,
er ist offenbar wieder einmal Phishing Angriffe gab deren Ziel an dieser Stelle wohl sein sollte auf das demokratische Wählerregister zuzugreifen.
Also wir wissen im November finden ja in den USA die Mitte am election Stadt das wird ein,
entscheidende Wahl für die Präsidentschaft Donald Trumps Missy zweite Hälfte und die zweite Amtsperiode Donald Trump ist das richtige,
und da werden jetzt auch wieder haking Aktivitäten,
registriert Facebook und Twitter wieder eine Reihe Propaganda Accounts gelöscht Microsoft die Hackergruppe apt28 bemerkt haben,
und vor all diesen Hintergründen testen die USA das WM per App because what could possibly go wrong Wladimir.
Und auf der Defqon der der coolen US Hacker Konferenz die jetzt,
letzten Wochenenden stattgefunden hat am volles Wochenendhäuser gefunden und wieder einmal alle Voting Computer auseinandergenommen da gibt's also ein Wort in computer village da wird dann regelmäßig alles rein getragen.
Was irgendwie Computer ist und als wahlmaschine verkauft wird und da wurde auch wieder alles zerlegt,
und gezeigt dass die IT Sicherheit der amerikanischen Wahlsystem schaurig ist.
Liste der amerikanischen.
Na na ja es ist mein wir haben.
Wir haben sie hatte ja Rob konkret am Ende am Ende unseres Vortrags über den PC Wahl hack auch noch mal zitiert erstaunlicherweise sind die einzigen Systeme die als,
sicher gelten sollen diejenigen die wir uns noch nicht angeschaut haben.
Und es ist schon erstaunlich sich das hier wieder also wie lange auch dieses Thema jetzt,
widder und sie beschäftigt ne also wir haben ja in Deutschland das Wahlcomputer Urteil mit Hilfe des CCC erreicht,
an der Wahl dass sich mehr oder weniger darauf beschränken lässt das.
Die Wahl geheim frei und vor allem der auszahlungs Vorgang auch für Laien nachvollziehbar sein muss was mehr oder weniger diese elektronischen Wahlsysteme einfach verbietet weil.
Eigentlich ein Computer nicht in der Lage ist etwas gleichermaßen nachvollziehbar und,
zu halten und gleichzeitig jeder einzelnen Wahlvorgang der stattgefunden hat geheim es gibt dann immer noch mal irgendein.
Doktoranden der seinen Professor überzeugt hat dass das mit mit blockchain und Doppel Krypto doch geht,
diese Ansätze scheitern aber daran dass sie von Laien nicht,
nachvollziehbar sind und deswegen grundsätzlich ungeeignet weil wenn das System nicht einfach nachvollziehbar ist dann liegt es umso mehr in den Händen einiger,
weniger eine Wahl zu manipulieren und eins ist ein Wahlsystem das nicht für alle automatisch nachvollziehbar ist.
Und zwar intuitiv und logisch ist eben ungeeignet ein Vertrauen in den demokratischen Vorgang in ihren einer Form zu begründen,
haben insofern ist es sinnvoll Bleibt es sinnvoll mit Stift und Papier zu wählen,
und selbst die IP die dahinter es ist Schrott bewerben letztes Jahr gezeigt haben nichtsdestotrotz Arne Schönbohm,
altes geehrter vorsitzender.
Des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik ist ja ganz beseelt von der Idee,
der online-wahlen der digitalen Wahl obwohl eigentlich ausnahmslos,
jeder Sicherheitsexperte die Hände,
auf dem Kopf zusammenschlägt wenn man von dieser Idee redet mir fällt einfach niemand ein der eine der irgendeinen Ruf in der IT Sicherheit Szene genießt der sagen würde Online-Wahl geile Idee,
gib einfach niemand.
Oder war Hauptcomputer in der Wahl und womit man finde ich diese Diskussion auch früh schon den,
Wind aus den Segeln nimmt es immer wieder der Hinweis es gibt eigentlich kaum etwas zu optimieren es gibt kaum etwas zu beschleunigen bei so einer Wahl ja
da ist einfach überhaupt nichts zu holen und das einzige Argument was ich immer wieder aufkommen sehe ist na ja das könnte ja dazu führen dass mehr Leute wählen gehen und das wäre ja toll,
ehrlich gesagt ich sehe das Gegenteil weil wenn das jetzt für dich noch mal eingeführt werden würde in Deutschland sehr unwahrscheinlich wegen dieses Wahlcomputer Urteil aber in einer längeren sehen wäre das ja wird es einfach mittelfristig eher dazu führen dass die Leute sagen fackelt
ja
Macht da mit Geräten irgendetwas ich habe keinerlei Möglichkeit das überhaupt noch nachzuvollziehen was dort passiert und ich glaube ich gar nichts also will ich doch gar nicht erst mit
das wird die einzige Konsequenz sein die Walross haben abgesehen davon kosten Menge Geld macht mir Stress und für die Legitimation einer Wahl,
selbst wenn sie korrekt abgelaufen ist einfach erschwert weil einfach Leute zu recht sagen können.
Aha macht das mit Computern das keiner wird ja dann wahrscheinlich Stimmen so und ihr könnt aber noch nicht mal das Gegenteil beweisen weil es sich nicht beweisen lässt lass es das,
Kernproblem also,
bitte bitte bitte bitte alle Leute die in irgendeiner Form und wie drüber nachdenken was ist das für eine tolle Idee halten ist einfach mal das Gegenteil von dem was ihr wollt.
Aber andererseits freue ich mich auch wenn wir in Deutschland weiterhin lustige Angriffsziele für den CCC haben.
Ja gut ist es ja nicht so dass da jetzt ein Mangel herrschen würde ne.
Nö aber keine sympal staatliche.
Also shameless self plugging indem
samankwe mit dieser ganzen Diskussion vielleicht noch nicht sich so sehr vertraut hat und sich jetzt die ganze Zeit denkt so hell und so und da muss es doch einen Weg geben und dann gibt doch bestimmt was mit Crypto und blockchain und Pipapo offen
die letztere insbesondere Letzteres password jetzt damals noch keine Rolle gespielt hat aber es ändert letztlich überhaupt nichts an der Grundsituation ich habe
Mütze ruhig Wiesner vor längerer Zeit wieder messenger Session her das ist wovon 3. April 2009 also schon fast
10 Jahre ja unglaublich von 9 Jahren Wahrheit die Entscheidung Bundesverfassungsgericht das Wahlcomputer Urteil das sogenannte und ich habe,
würde ich bis nach der hat einer der Kläger war darüber gesprochen und,
dieses Gespräch kann ich sehr empfehlen weil das wirklich noch mal sehr schön und einfach klar macht.
Warum das alles Unfug ist mit dem Ball Computern warum das eigentlich in Deutschland auch rechtlich keinen Bestand mehr haben sollte soll ich mit solchen Ideen aufzukommen,
also sei denn wir haben halt eine Zerstörung unseres Verfassungsgericht ist das ja nicht auszuschließen ist.
Und rammte erstmal ein paar neue Richter benennt dann.
Na also ich meine wenn wir uns hierauf wie noch mal eine AFD auf eine Regierungsebene eintreten dann wären wir halt das genauso abgehen sehen wie in Polen des Rittertums Justizsystem angezweifelt wird ecetera und,
irgendwann dann eben aus dem Verfassungsgericht zerschlagen wird noch ist nicht so weit aber wir sollten nicht glauben dass das Unmögliche.
Komm wir,
keine weiteren Meldung es gibt weitere Verfassungsbeschwerden gehen die Stars zu einer hat mir auch gesagt FDP und so weiter digital courage und,
die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte die wendet sich gegen,
das am 24 August 2017 in Kraft getretene Gesetz also exakt ein Jahr später mit einer Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen das Gesetz welches den den Einsatz von staatstrojanern eben in der Breite,
legalisiert die geneigten Hörerinnen erinnern sich damals sahen unter anderem,
Ulf buermeyer und ich also pohlmeyer von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und ich verkauf Computerclub als Sachverständige dort geladen ist es interessant,
bgff ihre Verfassungsbeschwerde begründet ne Ansatz hgff immer Betroffene finden
dir einen Anlass haben wir dann strategisch dieses Gesetz Weg klagen will jetzt gefunden haben als Beschwerdeführer ist der ARD Doping Experte Hajo Seppelt,
der im Exil also in Deutschland im Exil lebende türkischer Journalist Chan Dünndarm glaube ich mich von den aus ne.
Das kann sein ich bin des türkischen Zero mächtig.
Und Konstantin von Notz Mitglied des Bundestages jetzt kommt die Begründung.
Sie waren bereits mehrere Male im Rahmen ihrer Tätigkeiten Opfer von hacking Angriffen oder sind auf
Grund ihrer Position besonders gefährdet attackiert zu werden ganz klar nachvollziehbar nach apple hat sie mit der Russland angelegt dann dünner mit Erdogan und Konstantin von Notz.
Legt sich mit allen an.
Mit Allemann hinein an insbesondere mit den Geheimdiensten und so weiter ne der da wird der Maßen sicherlich zu einer anderen Beurteilung kochen wenn es um dessen Personal geht,
und sie sagen sie sind besonders darauf angewiesen dass die Bundesregierung der staatlichen Schutz fliegt aus dem sogenannten aytee Grundrecht nachkommt Simos Sicherheitslücken den Hersteller melden damit sie geschlossen werden können und nicht diese für staatliches hacking,
geheimer das ist denke ich ein entscheidender ein entscheidendes Argument gegen diese,
Idee des Staatstrojaner und ich hoffe natürlich dass diese Verfassungsbeschwerde Erfolg hat und wir hier eine Eingrenzung finden.
Ich wäre aber ich würde vorsichtig.
Sein ich will hier niemand auf falsche Ideen bringen aber es könnte natürlich möglich sein dass die.
Behörden sich eine Möglichkeit des Zugriffs auf Messenger-Dienste und Endgeräte.
Vorstellen die auch ohne Sicherheitslücken funktionieren könnte.
Und das wäre.
Relativ simpel Verpflichtung der Anbieter zur Mitwirkung insbesondere,
dem Ausspielen von spezifischer Malware auf spezifische Endgeräte also statt eines staatlichen Trojaners der dein WhatsApp oder telegram in irgendeiner Form hacked,
die Datenbank ausliest oder wie auch immer das passieren soll bekommst du einfach eine individuell infizierte.
WhatsApp oder telegram Version oder was auch immer das geht den er um jeden messenger ein ein messenger der vom.
Anbieter signiert wird dir als spezifische Update an dein Gerät Gegebenheiten der sich von allen anderen Messengern,
dein geht unterscheidet dass er eben über einen wie auch immer gearteten Seitenkanal deine Nachrichten lesbar macht das wäre so eine elegante Lösung gewisser Form die.
Keine Sicherheitslücken auf Geräten erfordern würde.
Und damit eben auch nicht die Masse in Gefahr bringen würde hier könnte also argumentiert werden ich ruhig,
Rolle spezifisch an ein Individuum auf dass wir abziehen für das für ein Richterbeschluss haben und so weiter diese spezifische shards of heraus die weil sie in diesem messenger drin ist,
auch nur im Kontext dieses Messengers tätig ist und damit eine Reihe der Argumente die Gegner dieses Vorgehens,
vorgetragen haben die zentral sind es ist schwer möglich eine Charts erfährt zu bauen die in eine dritte applikation eingreift.
Und deren Tätigkeit erfasst und überwacht und dabei nicht über die Befugnisse der Quellen Telekommunikations,
Überwachung hinausgeht BS ist dafür eine eine Sicherheitslücke notwendig die für alle Geräte,
Vorhandensein müsste also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das ein Weg ist auf den diese Diskussion,
irgendwann einmal hinauslaufen würde jetzt stellt sich.
Ja aber ist bisschen das Wort eine neue Diskussionen in mal ich höre jetzt so Begriffe Wiki Escrow und vector das ist doch im Prinzip.
Pietro ist ein anderes Problem TSV wäre immer noch etwas was auf die Masse gehen würde.
Husky risco heißt so ein Hinterlegung eines Schlüssels der sozialen dritten Zugang gibt auf.
Piaskowa in der in der einfachsten Lösung alle deine Nachrichten werden an deinen an deine Empfängerin
und an die Bundesregierung verschlüsselt und und unter richterliche Anordnung kann die Bundesregierung oder bekannt daneben
eine staatliche Institution sich diese Nachrichten geben lassen und sie mithilfe ihres masterkeys entschlüsseln
das setzte die einfachste Möglichkeit des GSV andere Idee,
alle geben Ihre Geheimschlüssel bei bei den staatlichen Stellen ab geht's verschiedene Lösungen aber die einfachste werden verschlüsselt einfach auch immer mit an die Partei aber das wird eben nicht,
das wird sich nicht durchsetzen lassen weil das wieder alle betreffen würde die den Ansatz nicht gerade skizziere ist
bei richterlicher an ohne bekommt eine C Person die zu dieser richterlichen Anordnung ist exakt den Messenger,
der dir dieser richterlichen Anordnung ist von in dem Fall Apple oder Google unter Zusammenarbeiten mit dem Anbieter des Messengers oder eben nicht,
ich würde Zusammenarbeit von Apple genügend als Update auf das Gerät und dann wären wir tatsächlich an einem Punkt wo wo das.
Mögliche der stellt sich die Frage welches Argument spricht dagegen das zu tun.
Und da denke ich gibt es ein sehr entscheidest Argument nämlich die Hersteller dieser Geräte.
Also jeder der was weiß ich Hardware oder Software für Kunden oder Produkte bereitstellt sollte,
deposit eine Rolle spielen sowie dass jemand vergleichen könnte mit der des Roten Kreuzes,
und und und Rettungssanitätern in Krisenregionen.
Nämlich dass man denen vertrauen kann dass du egal welche egal welcher Couleur du bist egal mit welchem,
mit welcher Kutsche du kennst.
Egal wie scheiße drauf ist.
Egal wie scheiße du bist Ärzte ohne Grenzen.
Hilft dir ja es gibt einfach und Partei,
Akteure in diesem Konflikt der Endziel der Schutz des Lebens ist.
Und diese Rolle würde ich eigentlich bei diesem großen Unternehmen Konzern aussehen,
dass man die da nicht reinziehen kann denn wenn es jetzt quasi eine Gesetzgebung gebe die,
die bedeutet ok auf richterliche Anordnung muss Apple dir eine Trojan VII Version von cygne auf dein iPhone spielen.
Und das ist einfach Gesetz das wird so durchgeführt dass dass wir zugetan dann wäre das also ich meine hättest Du jetzt nicht diese der der Staat wäre dann nicht mehr nur,
jemand der Sicherheitslücken Gehen dein System heute Sonne jemand der ganz klar auf richterliche Anordnung sogar dein in dein Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen jedem Softwarehersteller,
und jeden Hardware Hersteller den du dich anvertraust,
eingreifen und dieses kompromittieren kann insofern das nur als Ausblick wohin diese Debatte gehen wird,
merke das ja wenn ich mit den Leuten die diese Ideen haben spreche dass es immer wieder,
so ominöse Andeutung guten Woche können sich Heuschrecken um jemanden zu hacken,
natürlich Formen Sicherheitslücke wenn diese Sicherheitslücke eben ist das der Hersteller einer Software eine Schatz verpflichtet ist eine Schadsoftware
für den Betrieb auf deinem Gerät zu signieren genauso eine Sicherheitslücke
aber das wäre eine Sicherheitslücke bei der man argumentieren kann das für die Bevölkerung zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr besteht und ich vermute dass wir mit diesem mit dieser Herangehensweise
in dieser Diskussion innerhalb der nächsten zwei oder drei Jahre wahrscheinlich sogar innerhalb der nächsten 1 oder 2 Jahre konfrontiert werden.
Also ich kann nur alle Betten inklusive der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und alle anderen Beschwerdeführer sich auf diese Herangehensweise.
Vorzubereiten und da eben auch juristische moralische und,
ökonomische Argumente vorzubereiten warum auch das schlecht ist ich halte es wie gesagt ich halte der gedeckelt ganze Reihe Argumente für insbesondere wer soll unseren scheiß denn noch kaufen.
Wenn klar ist dass unsere mit dass das dass unsere das was auch immer in Deutschland zum Einsatz kommt zum mit wie eine Mitwirkungspflicht gegenüber deutschen,
Behörden hatte ich mich auch schon mal hinter verschlossener Tür mit Herstellern gestritten ich gesagt habe mein doch nicht ernsthaft,
dass ihr eure Sicherheitsprodukte noch annähernd jemand verkauft kriegt.
Wenn klar ist dass ihr mit mit irgendwelchen Behörden zusammen arbeitet und dass das ekelhafte und leider auch nachvollziehbare Argument war nur ganz ehrlich ich glaube wir könnten wir unser Marc würde sich dadurch
öffnen denn es gibt eine ganze Menge starten die das nachfragen indivia die quasi unsere Produkte individuell importieren dürfen wenn wir,
staatliche Backdoors erlauben also die staatliche Vektor als Zukunftsmarkt.
Das wird auch als Thema nicht von der.
Von der Bildfläche verschwinden auch wenn wir technisch uns gerade in einer Zeit wähnen wo wir diese Probleme vielleicht über meinen,
überschritten zu haben das halte ich für noch nicht ganz den Fall mit dass du trotz,
alles Glück an digital courage FDP und Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte mit den Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen den Staatstrojaner,
deutscher Anwaltsverein hier auch noch zu nennen in der Verfassungsbeschwerde die dass die dgff eingereicht hat und.
Ja Holger der Kampf geht weiter.
Auch gegen google geht der Kampf weiter der Kampf den man vielleicht glaubt gar nicht zu führen weil Google tut er so tolle Dinge für ein und hat prima Dienste die oft ziemlich gut funktionieren manchmal vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu gut funktionieren
eine dieser Funktion ist die sogenannte wie heißt das noch mal offiziell Zeitachse.
Timeline oder.
Standortdaten.
Ich weiß nicht genau wie der englische Begriff heißt der deutsche ist Zeitachse Timeline klingt jetzt plausibel dass ist das Aufzeichnen der eigenen Position,
in Google Maps z&w auf Android Telefon unter Umständen auch mit einer etwas über geordneten Infrastruktur ich weiß nicht ganz genau
wie das Mapping dort ist da dort ja Google Maps auch das Mapping System für alle Apps darstellt könnte das an der Stelle etwas anders aufgehangen sein,
es gibt halt konkret dieses Feature der Zeitachse was man aktivieren kann nur sagen kann bitte meinen standortverlauf auch speichern denn ich will das und ich möchte das gerne
nachschlagen wann kriegt man also eine abstrahierte
Bewegungslinie mit naja du warst da ein paar Stunden Imbiss ungefähr hier lang gefahren von dann bis dann und dann hasse ich an dem Ordner aufgehalten das ganze natürlich,
doppelt mit Solar
standen so Standort lookup mit naja sieht so aus als ob du in diesem Restaurant gewesen bist dann fragt sich das System auch gerne mal warst du denn da kannst du ja sagen und so weiter an dann kriegst du quasi so für dich selber zum Nachschlagen ist ja auch
praktisch sein kann Sonderauswertung mit ihr
mach da warst du behalten wenn man halt zu später mal nachdenkt ob wir was wieso bin ich denn jetzt hier geblitzt worden irgendwie war ich da überhaupt ein Stück mal nach so ja war ich.
Hey Google wo war ich gewesen.
Genau also,
na wofür man auch immer das benutzt aber man muss es einschalten zum Schützemann kannst auch ausschalten stellt sich raus surprise surprise,
diese Sammlung der Standortdaten findet auch statt wenn man das Feature deaktiviert hat Google mittlerweile auch zugegeben und,
bitte jetzt nicht so gut.
Ramazan könnte unter Umständen teuer werden.
Ich bin mal gespannt also ich habe das jetzt technisch nicht nachvollzogen aber es ist passt auch mal wieder so wie Arsch auf Augen.
Ja und ich freue mich halt irgendwie ist das ein Fehler wenn das ein Fehler ist wie kann.
Ja das dauert.
Das nicht entdecken ja schon sehr schlimm sie bisschen in die oft.
Dann mal noch was mit Hakenkreuz.
H&M Kreuze Hakenkreuz Videospiele pünktlich zur gamescom also das ist ja eh aufgefallen jetzt war ja war oder ist ja Videospielmesse in Kölle ne.
Kommen unseren Freund von der Bundeswehr.
Die Bundeswehr groß und breit vertreten ja mit seiner was hatten die für eine Werbekampagne diesmal ihr wieso.
Mehr auf dem Boot geht nicht.
Mehr Open World geht nicht,
Multiplayer in echt und solche Scherze er wollen also haben sich gedacht na ja guck mal oder wolltest du nicht wenn du wenn du hier schon so schön,
was heißt ich Counter Strike oder Wolfenstein 3D spielt dann kannst du doch auch mal im echten Leben als Kanonenfutter dienen,
übrigens kleiner kleiner im Kleingedruckten steht du hast nur ein Leben aber da steht nur im Kleingedruckten.
Filmcenter fand ja ich meine jahrelange mussten wir uns hier die eine Debatte die haben wir hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik nur selten,
erwähnt weil die dann tatsächlich ist also eine der Debatten hier irgendwann tatsächlich mal vorbei war Killerspiel Debatte ne da hattest du dann diesen diesen Amok laufenden in Winnenden wenn ich mir nicht,
da war dann der hatte einen Computer gehabt und hatte auch in die Ballerspiele draufgespielt also war klar wenn der den Computer nicht gehabt hätte,
dann hätte der niemals diese Schießerei in der Schule gemacht das hatte dass der Vater Waffen hatte war jetzt ein anderes Thema Anne also das damit hat das ja nichts zu tun.
Und das war wirklich also jahrelanges Thema dann wurde er haben eigentlich alle Studien gezeigt die Personen die solche Ballerspiele spielen leiden jetzt nicht an überdurchschnittlichem Aggressionspotential hegen keine Tötung,
Fantasien aber die Bundeswehr,
hat da entgegen der Forschung auf eine Zielgruppe entdeckt und wendet sich dort einmal wieder mit.
Sehr interessanten Angeboten an das dann doch größtenteils Jugendliche.
Publikum dieser Messung bei natürlich dass nicht nur Jugendliche sind sehr auch viel erwachsene Leute die.
Bisschen aktiver und Umgang mit dem passiv Medium Fernsehen pflegen.
Was ich sehr geil fand also zur Eröffnung der gamescom ich folge ja vielen Politikern auf Twitter,
neben den Journalisten und Psychopathen,
auch Politiker und Politikerinnen und die haben meine Güte was haben die sich alle an diese gamescom.de angewandt,
ich will hier ist healthy vom Stand von Ubisoft oder leider kann ich nicht zur gamescom kommen oder FDP dann direkt zu wir müssen Gesetze ändern
Videospiel Standort nur 10 Deutschland werden und es war wirklich schon so ein bisschen peinlich ich habe dann gesagt das Spiel ist aus,
wer sich bis jetzt nicht an die gamescom dran gemacht hat hat verloren hat aber niemanden davon abgehalten trotzdem noch irgendwie.
Sich da zu bemühen
und so gibt's alle allerhand Geschenke zur zur gamescom amazon hat extra zwei Wochen vor der gamescom Fahrpreise erhöht,
um sie dann medienwirksam zu entkommen Bücher zu senken das auch sehr schöne Visualisierung der Amazon Preise von irgend welchen Grafikkarten so also gamescom ist,
thing so und selbst die die USK.
Die unabhängige Selbstkontrolle in der Unterhaltungssoftware hat ein Geschenk zur gamescom pünktlich veröffentlich denn,
sie wollen jetzt,
bei der Bestimmung der Altersfreigabe von spielen in den Hakenkreuze ss Symbole und weitere Kennzeichen verfassungswidriger Organisationen verwendet werden die sogenannte sozial,
Adäquanz Klausel mit,
einbeziehen ich habe diese sozialadäquanzklausel tatsächlich nicht im Wortlaut gefunden weil ich die im StGB 83 nicht sehe aber dass ich wahrscheinlich einen alten.
Ich habe auch online geguckt habe ich es eh nichts gefunden ist halt gerade irgendwas neu.
Also es,
die Klausel hat inhaltlich im Prinzip Ausnahmen für den StGB 83 im Bereich der Lehre der Kunst oder der staatsbürgerlichen Aufklärung also wenn du irgendwas hier,
also irgendjemand muss den Leuten ja mal zeigen wie ein Hakenkreuz aussieht.
Sag mal weißt du was ist verbotenes.
Damit man weiß dass man das nicht am jüdischen Friedhof hinsprühen darf,
muss man ja es gibt Leute den musste das erklären so den muss da muss jemand hingehen und sagen passen auf du du scheiß Symbol darfst du nicht machen.
Und genauso in der Kunst ne musst ja hier Jonathan Meese muss ja auch von irgendwas leben,
der sich da die ganze Zeit mit Hitler vergleicht oder was auch immer der muss ja auch irgendwie noch ein bisschen was machen können ohne die ganze Zeit angezeigt zu werden obwohl das natürlich dann grüße sie ist aber egal und staatsbürgerlicher Aufklärung und jetzt geht's eben die Frage.
Achso und außerdem wenn das im Rahmen der Ablehnung der NS-Ideologie stattfindet also hier so dass,
klassische Symbol gegen Nazis mit dem zerschlagenen Hakenkreuz ne geht's ja dann auch weiß ich war schon vor 20 Jahren dann irgendwelche Leute die wegen Verwendung Verfassungsrechts verfassungswidriger
Symbole in wie angesagt wurden bei sind gegen Nazis Symbol irgendwie am am Anorak Klemmen hatten.
Genau das ist er dafür gibt's im Ausnahmen und davon gibt's jetzt eben auch die Überlegung dass das bei den Computer spielen in der Form berücksichtigt,
werden kann oder soll und vor allem hier na ich denke braucht man sich hier beziehen will also auf Kunst ist,
sich eine Möglichkeit aber auch natürlich wenn eine Ablehnung der NS-Ideologie erkennbar ist weil so ein Spiel wie Wolfenstein dessen Inhalt ja primär ist dass man Nazis tötet.
Sehen Sie also hier,
eine Möglichkeit dann auch zu sagen du wenn du solange du dir tötest ist die Verwendung dieses Symbols dann auch in Ordnung ist das nachvollziehbar ich frag mich gefragt wie du dazu stehst überd.
Das frage ich mich ehrlich gesagt auch also weiß ja dass meine.
Dass ich nicht so eine intensive Auseinandersetzung mit Videospielen Pflege,
von daher ist mir auch gerade überhaupt nicht klar präsent das Thema da irgendwie ist
grundsätzlich bin ich ja durchaus dafür dass man diese Symbole nicht durch übermäßiges verbieten auch noch aufwerten,
wollte und sie gerade in einem
geschichtlichen Kontext auch problemlos zeigen zu können ist klar von daher macht sie nach Ausnahme auf jeden Fall sind ob es diese Ausnahme auf so spiele generell gelten sollte.
Ich mich also erstmal fragen welche wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse in diesem Bereich bewirkt hat oder nicht bewölkt.
Kann ich in aufgrund eines Mangels an Varianz wirst du da wahrscheinlich wenig Studien zu fühlen können also kannst jetzt eben sagen,
also für eine Stuhl von der Ärztin im Studio bräuchtest du ja zwei vergleichbare Fälle und dann werden Deutschland diese Verwendung größtenteils eingeschränkt haben kann man da eben auch nicht sagen ob das jetzt nee fact hatte oder nicht weil man keine Vergleichsgruppe hat.
Hat das auf jeden Fall nicht dazu geführt dass wir keine Nazi.
Bitte ganz kurz was weil ich gerade sagte dass ich in den Paragraph 83 nicht,
dedy sozialadäquanzklausel finde doch die befindet sich da drin da steht nämlich Paragraph 86 Absatz 3 und 4 gelten entsprechend das heißt man muss hier wieder,
klicken auf den Paragraph 86 und da ist eine sozialadäquanzklausel drin.
Geht nicht wenn das Propagandamittel oder die Handlung der staatsbürgerlichen Aufklärung der Abwehr von verfassungswidrigen Bestrebungen der Kunst oder der Wissenschaft der Forschung oder der Lehre der Berichterstattung über Vorgänge des Zeitgeschehens oder,
der Geschichte oder ähnlichen Zwecken dient das total Adäquanz pausenuhr.
Was heißt die eigentliche Frage ist.
Oder ist.
Der oder ist Wolfenstein die Abwehr verfassungswidriger Bestrebungen.
Welches Spiel hat denn diese Freigabe jetzt ab 12 bekommen das wo man die Nazis abmetzeln soll oder.
Davon gehe ich aus denn umgekehrt wird es nicht möglich sein ne.
Ja through the darkest of time.
Und das hat eine Freigabe ab 12 bekommen das Video auch noch mal Euro-Länder man könnte auch sagen Hakenkreuze erst ab 18.
Das Spiel setzt sich kritisch mit der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus in deutschen Auswanderer na ja.
Guck mal bei weil wir Inglourious Basterds durfte Wie heißt dann Ich will Google Mister will Smith sagen aber der heißt.
Brad Pitt darf er auch mit Pizza Menden Hakenkreuz in die Stirn von dem Nazi ritzen.
Ja
Aber der war auch ab 18 glaube ich.
Michael Kay Tarantino ziemlich wahrscheinlich.
Würde ich vermuten dass der Film ab 18 war.
Also hat.
Ja also keine Ahnung ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass dem eine keine so große Bedeutung.
Appetit hat doch gar nicht damit.
Bitte hast du Inglourious Basterds nicht geguckt hat die Hauptrolle im Film Brad Pitt hat die Hauptrolle in Inglourious Basterds.
Achso ich bin gerade ich bin gerade bei dem falschen Film gelandet Entschuldigung.
Was hast du.
Naja einem anderen der auch Inglourious Basterds heißt das ist so ziemlich nicht I.
Also Brad Pitt hat der arbeit dermaßen die Hauptrolle gespielt.
Basso Bastards oder Pass.
Ich sehe die das.
Terz heißt der nicht Bastard sondern Bastard bastard was ist eine italienische Film aus den Siebzigern Basterds ist die Tarantino war.
Deine Worten was Inglourious Basterds nicht gesehen.
Doch ich habe ihn gesehen aber Wolfram ich jetzt mal.
Habe ich auch Kaffee bekommen.
Ja da kann meinetwegen auch für jeden Filmen Oscar bekommen das schreibt mir immer angemessen zu sein aber er hat auch Til Schweiger mitgespielt also.
Ja aber der hat glaube ich nichts gesagt der hat nur geguckt.
Wurde nur erschossen.
Bester Film beste Regie bestes Originaldrehbuch bester Nebendarsteller bester Schnitt beste Kamera bester Ton bester Tonschnitt für 8 Oscars nominiert und auf jeden Fall der Nazi Film mit dem besten Ende.
Oder kein Oscar bekommen oder.
Doch natürlich für die besten Nebendarsteller Christopher.
Achso okay gut ein.
Gott mit Brad Pitt meinetwegen.
Ok.de.
Ich habe auch nichts gegen bettfertig findet ganz toll aber ehrlich gesagt ich habe den Film einmal gesehen habe.
Es wird die Rolle seines Lebens in den Film.
Großartig also der das ist das ist tatsächlich sehr geil will in Sterzhausen muss dazusagen solche Filme kannst also eigentlich alle Filme kannst ja nur in der Originalversion gucken.
Und Brad Pitt in Inglourious Basterds ist.
Die Rolle seines Lebens sorry das ist nicht die Rolle so ist.
Dann vielleicht noch hat Erich wie Brad Pitt in in snatch mit Jana dann hat er da die unseren gesehen was ist die beste welche Rolle ok dann klären wir das jetzt im Internet schwierig da die beste Rolle Edward Norton.
Ja das stimmt alles auch wieder trotzdem.
Na also guck mal hier Brad Pitt Wikipedia pl.
Lassen sich über Filme streiten ich habe schon mehrfach bewiesen dass das Podcast nicht.
Mit den Leuten mit denen oder die Freak.
Das stimmt da einig.
Also ich hinters Funktion.
Hat auch einen anderen Podcast nicht funktioniert kann kann auch an mir liegen.
Ja vielleicht ja Tim vielleicht nicht inside me ja ich würde sagen schon.
Visit wie meinst du wirklich mein hast dich noch nicht mit Holger über hast Du noch nicht mit Holgi über Filme heute ein das würdest du dir gar nicht trauen.
Mit Holgi ist E-Maschine.
Dießemer das meine ich doch auch.
Aber die Schweiz im wenn du halt auch immer nur über Bladerunner und Brazil sprechen willst dann muss der Film.
Stimmt da nicht will auch über MMI reden aber will ja auch keiner mit mir zurück.
Herder Fahrräder für Schocker das war sehr amüsant.
Man verzweifelt 1 bis.
Filme 2001 zft die heutigen Twitter und sonstwas Gehirn Einheit innerhalb beim Intro noch hat schlafen.
Die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne aber Podcasts machen ne Oma das passt doch alles nicht zusammen es ist eine grausame Welt.
Wir halten fest in.
Schauen wir mal wie sich das entwickelt inflationäre Verwendung von Hakenkreuzen in Videospielen oder in der in der Rest Welt,
sehe ich bisher noch nicht und ich glaube ich werde zumindest will ich sein die Maßgabe die hier stattfindet davon gesagt solange ihr die Nazis solange Spiele Zitat die Nazis am Ende zu töten,
oder über deren Idiotie und Boshaftigkeit aufzuklären erlauben wir auch die Verwendung des passendes Symbol ist glaube ich dass das hier,
dass man hier den Mut haben muss den Rezipienten der Spiele.
So viel Intelligenz noch zuzutrauen ich weiß das wenn man sich in der Öffentlichkeit um schaut man immer weniger Hoffnung hat,
das noch Rest Intelligenz in unserer Spezies vorhanden ist aber ohne die zu,
zu fordern und zu fördern ist sie im auch dem Untergang geweiht insofern hier alles klar alles klar,
Nazis aus starten ab 12 Uhr können wir mal machen und gucken wohin das führt.
Ich würde allerdings die Alternative wäre gewesen die haben alle wieder Brandner so eine Machete in der Hand und so einen roten runden rotes Häkchen Opfer Jacke aber da jetzt hätte ich auch wieder ein Riesentheater gegeben also wie du machst machst du falsch.
Ja Siemens.
An dieser Stelle müssen wir dem Thorsten danken thorsten hat unseren unser Problem in der letzten Sendung festgestellt dass wir nämlich kein endlos Musikbett für die Termine haben und er hat Abhilfe geschaffen vielen Dank.
Also das ganze führt zu unserem Termin.
So und da sind ja auch schon es geht los am 26 August 2018
in Europa haben eine europaweiten Aktionstag gegen die upload-filter und das Leistungsschutzrecht,
wir haben ja hier ausführlich darüber schon berichtet in insgesamt 24 Städten in zehn Ländern sind Aktionen geplant darunter so Industriestädte wie Paris,
Wien.
Graz Bergen.
Berlin Helsinki Stuttgart.
Mainz.
München.
Zagreb und es gibt eine ständig aktualisierte Liste auf save you Internet. Today.
Genau danke dann mal gucken Julia Reda würde sich besonders freuen.
Denke ich auch dann eröffnet am
1. September in Lübeck der no-break space weder der wird betrieben vom chaotikum eV und ist die Heimat Treffpunkt des dortigen
Chaostreff die Eröffnung des neuen no-bake faces beginnt um 14 Uhr mit einem gemütlichen familientaugliche Grillfest auf dem Parkplatz hinter unserem Gebäude und im Laufe des Tages wird es dann in Zweifelsfall immer,
billiger familientauglich Dennis geht ein Hacker jeopardy eine Hüpfburg Kuchen und Bier alles natürlich nur für die Erwachsenen nein abends wird aufgelegt ich glaube das wird ganz nett deren schönen neuen space der wird groß aufgemacht,
kann man meiningen.
Bringt ausreichend familienfreundlich
ja und dann steht vom 22 was 28.10 wie von uns schon erwähnt die Privacy Weg in Wien an und S7 schönen Motor Generationen und dafür gibt's jetzt auch
Tickets zu kaufen spricht der Vorverkauf ist eröffnet ihr könnt dabei sein wir wären auch dabei.
Und es gibt sogar einen stream Coca Ticket also wenn man die Veranstaltung einfach nur aus Graz oder Salzburg unterstützen möchte oder aus Deutschland dann kann man das Stream Ticket kaufen.
VDD tja könnt ihr auch Astrid X verkaufen das wäre ein Aufruhr.
Paywall auf Media CCC de.
AL-KO greskötter sogar funktionieren nicht ganz unsere mit.
Damit sind wir am Ende der schlechten Nachrichten angekommen es gibt mehr es gibt für mich noch die Aufgabe ein bisschen Dank los zu dann willst du noch abschließende Bemerkungen.
Äußern ja ich hatte ja neulich mal hier meinen Dauerauftrag Spendenaufruf platziert.
Ist erfolgreich geworden habe ich gestern in der Freakshow gehört.
War ziemlich erfolgreich kann man kann man schon sagen also ist Wodka lässt lässt sich zum aktuellen Zeit und noch nicht abschließend betrachten da will ich mal den August noch an mir vorbeirauschen lassen und das habe ich auch schon vorher bestellt.
Besteht ein neues Auto vor der Tür Tim.
Texte für seinen Ferrari überhaupt mit Anhänger.
Zufluss sonderanfertigung.
Ich habe gespart.
Nein also viele haben sich bereit erklärt hier in diesem Dauerauftrags Modus zu wechseln was mich sehr freut auf viele viele die vielen vielen kleinen Spenden machen einfach
den Unterschied das ist das Ding abgesehen davon dass mich einfach die schiere
Bereitschaft schon immer wieder beeindruckt und das wird Druck gerade motivierend und ja das wird
dann auch in der Zukunft wenn es so weitergeht noch so einiges hier ermöglichen was ich bisher vielleicht immer ausgeschlossen habe,
willst keine Versprechungen machen aber es ist doch jetzt Schluss hier.
Ja ich werde an dieser Stelle dann noch danken ja insbesondere Alexandra Aaron und Pascal ich danke euch herzlich für die Unterstützung Richter möchte noch mal Thorsten für das Musik bedanken das fand ich sehr schön,
wenn das Internet hier so das war so wie bei am.
Unaufgefordert und Hilfe.
Könnte sie auch interessieren habe ich war gemacht kostenlos frei Haus.
Genau.
Also vielen Dank euch für die regelmäßige Unterstützung unserer.
Klein Gruppentherapie die wir hier erhältlich aufnehmen.
Die ist jetzt vorbei bis bald.